ALL THE SENATE BUDGET IN FISCAL
REVIEWS SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER ONE
TO ORDER. AND I AM GOING TO MAKE
A FEW COMMENTS THAT YOU'VE HEARD
MANY TIMES BEFORE THANK GOD YOU
HAVEN'T MEMORIZED THEM AND ARE
NOT SAYING THEM OUT LOUD WITH
ME. AS WE CONTINUE TO TAKE SOME
PRECAUTIONS TO MANAGE ONGOING
COVERT NINETEEN RHYS. OF THE
SENATE CONTINUES TO WELCOME THE
PUBLIC AND HAS PROVIDED ACCESS
TO BOTH IN PERSON AND
TELECONFERENCE BRITISH IMPATIENT
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT. FOR
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE AND I
WILL DESCRIBE WHEN WE'RE DOING
THAT- LATER- THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE
IS- POSTED ON THE SCREEN IS ALSO
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE. OUR
WEBSITE I WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW
TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. 468-163-8772
TWO SIX EIGHT ONE SIX THREE AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS. SEVEN THREE
SIX TWO EIGHT THREE THREE. I
WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AND ANY
INDIVIDUALS WHOSE DISRUPTIVE MAY
BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WE'RE HOLDING
OUR COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN
THE- STREET BUILDING- ALL
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE
SHOULD REPORT BUT A SENATOR
MINUTES REPORTED AND WE EXPECT
CENTER GROW CHOI BOGUE SHORTLY.
AND WILL ESTABLISH OUR CORPSMAN
BEGIN HEARING- THOSE PROVIDING
TESTIMONY BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
TODAY ARE ALSO PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY FOR A REMOTE
PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE YOUR
PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS WILL
GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING ANY
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. AND I ASKED
THAT EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED. OF THAT YOU USED TO
RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM. EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO ON MUTE. PLEASE
SELECT ON MUTE BEFORE YOU BEGIN
SPEAKING R. I. T. PERSONNEL WILL
PUT YOU BACK ON MUTE WHEN YOU'RE
DONE. ONCE RECOGNIZED AS PLEASE
MAKE SURE THAT YOU CAN BE SEEN
ON THIS SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME
AND THEN YOU'RE READY TO ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW PUBLIC
ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC IN THE HEARING ROOM
TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW.
AND WILL BE USING THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFIED TODAY AS WELL. PUBLIC%
COMMENT WILL BE HEARD AFTER ALL
DISCUSSION ITEMS HAVE BEEN
PERCENT- BEFORE WE BEGIN LET'S
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. DR FRANCIS
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. CENTER
LAYERED HERE CENTER LAYERED HERE
SENATOR MEN CENTER MEN HERE
SENATOR A CHILLED BOWL. WE HAVE
CORN GREAT- WE HAVE A QUORUM- IT
HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED IN TODAY'S
HEARING WE HAVE NINE DISCUSSION
ITEMS- AND THEY WILL BE FOR THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM HASTINGS COLLEGE OF THE
LAW CALIFORNIA STATE LIBRARY AND
THE CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION. WE WILL BE
DISCUSSING ALL THE ISSUES LISTED
INDISCRETIONS. AGENDA FIRST TAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT SECOND AND
FINALLY TAKE OUR VOTES ON
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS THAT WE
DISCUSSED IN OUR PRIOR FEBRUARY
SUBCOMMITTEE HEARINGS AND THAT
WILL BE THE VOTE ONLY ITEMS WILL
BE ITEMS ONE THROUGH TWENTY ONE
AND WE WORE AS I JUST SAID DO
THAT VOTE AFTER THE PUBLIC
COMMENT IN CASE THERE'S ANY
PUBLIC COMMENT THAT IS A
RELEVANT TO IT. SO WE'RE GOING
TO BEGIN- WITH ISSUE NUMBER
TWENTY TWO IT'S THE HIGHER
EDUCATION STUDENT HOUSING GRANT
PROGRAM WE HAVE JENNIFER KACU
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
JASON CONSTANT TOURISTS FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
SAID JOB FOR MEN FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA WAS SET
NAVARETTE FROM THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE. AND VICE AND ONE FROM
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
AND WE ARE REALLY GOING TO TRY
TO GET THROUGH THIS HEARING BY
ELEVEN THIRTY AND EARLIER IF
POSSIBLE SO. I WOULD JUST
CAUTION PEOPLE AS WE MOVE ALONG
FROM THIS IS NOT TIME TO REPEAT
THEIR ENTIRE DISSERTATION SO- WE
APPRECIATE. EVERYBODY'S PRESENCE
AND WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN ON
ISSUE TWENTY TWO WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SO WELCOME
TO THE COMMITTEE. THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING MEMBER JENNIFER WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. AS A PART
OF MY REMARKS I WILL PROVIDE A
BRIEF BACKGROUND OF THE HIGHER
EDUCATION STUDENT HOUSING GRANT
PROGRAM ESTABLISHED LAST YEAR.
FINANCES RECOMMENDATIONS THE
JOINT LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
COMMITTEE THAT WERE DUE ON MARCH
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO AND THEN
THE PROPOSED GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INVESTMENT. THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BUDGET ACT ESTABLISHED THE
HIGHER EDUCATION STUDENT HOUSING
GRANT PROGRAM WHICH SET ASIDE
TWO BILLION ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND OVER A THREE YEAR PERIOD TO
ESTABLISH A LOW COST STUDENT
HOUSING GRANT PROGRAM FOR THE
PAST PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION
SEGMENTS. FOCUSED ON EXPANDING
THE AVAILABILITY OF AFFORDABLE
STUDENT HOUSING. THE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE FOR THIS PROGRAM
SB ONE SIXTY NINE APPROPRIATED
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND IN FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO THE FIRST
INSTALLMENT OF FUNDING. OF THE
APPROPRIATED FUNDING UP TO
TWENTY FIVE MILLION IS AVAILABLE
TO CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
TO SUPPORT PLANNING GRANTS TO
DETERMINE IF IT IS FEASIBLE FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE TO CONSTRUCT
AN OFFER AFFORDABLE STUDENT.
HOUSING ON MARCH FIRST TWENTY
TWO DEPARTMENT OF. SUBMIT A
LETTER TO THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE
BUDGET COMMITTEE WITH A LIST OF
RECOMMENDED CONSTRUCTION
PROJECTS TO BE FUNDED IN THE
FIRST ROUND OF FUNDING. A LIST
OF ELIGIBLE CONSTRUCTION
PROJECTS THAT THAT THE
DEPARTMENT IS NOT RECOMMENDED
THE FUNDING OUT OF THE FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION. APPROPRIATED
FOR FISCAL YEAR TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. AND THE LIST OF
PROJECTS THAT FINANCE DEPARTMENT
TO BE AN ELIGIBLE. FOR THE
AVAILABLE CONSTRUCTION GRANT
FUNDING THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE PRIORITIZE SUPPORT FOR
PROPOSED PROJECTS. THAT
REFLECTED AN INTERSECTIONAL
HOUSING ARRANGEMENT AND THEN
PRIORITIZE FURTHER APPLICATIONS
BASED ON A WEIGHTED RANKING.
THAT COMBINED AN APPLICANT STATE
SUPPORTED KERBECK CONSTRUCTION
COSTS. AN APPLICANT'S PROPOSED
STUDENT RENTAL RATES. AND NOT
LETTER TO THE JAIL BC FINANCES
ALSO SUBMITTED A LIST OF
PLANNING GRANTS TO BE AWARDED TO
COLLEGES. REQUESTING PLANNING
GRANTS AND PLANNING GRANT. WAS
PRIORITIZED SUPPORT EARLY STAGE
PLANNING ACTIVITIES FOR ALL
COLLEGES REQUESTING PLANNING
GRANTS. FINALLY THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSES SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND. THE SECOND INSTALLMENT OF
THE PLANNED TWO BILLION ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND APPROPRIATION. THE
HIGHER EDUCATION STUDENT HOUSING
GRANT PROGRAM. THANK. YOU AND
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY- DO
QUESTIONS AFTER. EVERYONE HAS
SPOKEN NEXT WE'LL GO TO THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST. HE'S IN
CONSTANT TO ROGELIO. WHEN WE
REVIEWED THE ADMINISTRATION'S
RECOMMENDED LAST AROUND ONE
PROJECTS THAT LIST APPEARED
REASONABLE TO US ON THE
METHODOLOGY THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION USED GENERALLY
ALIGNS WITH THE STATUTORY
GUIDANCE. WE WOULD EMPHASIZE
THAT THE LEGISLATURE HAS MANY
OPTIONS AVAILABLE TO IT TOO-
ISSUE ROUND ONE GRANTS AND
THAT'S BECAUSE THE STATURE RIGHT
GUIDANCE IS RATHER BROAD. AND WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE BEGIN
WEIGHING ALTERNATIVE APPROACHES
AGAINST THE US DEPARTMENT
FINANCES RECOMMENDED LESS. AND
TERMINATE SHOULD PRODUCE OUR
BEST ALIGNS WITH ITS OUR
PRIORITIES FOR THE GRANT PROGRAM
. YOU WILL HEAR A LOT OF VARIOUS
ALTERNATIVE APPROACHES- FROM US
YOU'LL HEAR THEM FROM THE
SEGMENTS WELL WE GIVE OUR OWN
SET OF- ALTERNATIVE APPROACHES
BEGINNING ON PAGE FIFTEEN OF
YOUR AGENDA. BUT IN REVIEWING
ALL THESE ALTERNATIVE APPROACHES
WE THINK A GOOD STARTING POINT
IS AGAIN TO THINK ABOUT WHAT THE
LEGISLATURE'S GOALS FOR THE
PROGRAM ARE- IN OUR VIEW THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCES APPROACH
REALLY EMPHASIZES COLLEGE
AFFORDABILITY. AND IF THAT IS
THE LEAD THE LEGISLATURE
FUNDAMENTAL- OBJECTIVE HERE THEN
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
RECOMMENDED LAST IS A REASONABLE
STARTING POINT. THAT'S IT IF THE
LEGISLATURE HAS BROADER
OBJECTIVES SUCH AS AN EXPANDING
A MOMENT CAPACITY OR- PROVIDING
RELIEF TO AREAS THAT HAVE
PARTICULARLY TIGHT HOT HOUSING
MARKETS. THAT COULD WARRANT
MORE- SUBSTANTIAL MODIFICATIONS
THE LAST THAT WAS RECOMMENDED BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. WE
ALSO KNOW THAT WHATEVER PROJECTS
ARE SELECTED FOR ROUND ONE. WILL
COME WITH THE RISK OF.
EXPERIENCING COST OVERRUNS AND
THEREFORE. ACTUALLY CHANGES IN
THEIR PROPOSED SCOPE FOR
AFFORDABLE RENTS. AND HELP
MITIGATE THOSE RISKS WELL WE
RECOMMEND OF THREE CHANGES TO
THEIR PROGRAMS EXISTING STATUTE.
OF THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS START
ON PAGE SIXTEEN OF YOUR AGENDA
BUT THEY GENERALLY FOCUS ON-
SETTING ASIDE FUNDS FOR PROJECT
CONTINGENCY. WE FOCUS ON
ESTABLISHING A NOTIFICATION
PROJECT PROCESS WHEN THERE IS A
NOTABLE CHANGE IN A PROJECTS-
SCOPING COSTS. AND ALSO-
RECOMMENDATIONS AROUND
STRENGTHENING SOME OF THE
EXISTING REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
LAID ON STATUTE. ASSEMBLY I
WANTED TO KNOW- ONE QUICK-
ADDITION- TO THIS PROGRAM
PROPOSED UNDER THE SENATE OF
DEMOCRAT BUDGET PLAN. UNDER THE
SUN SENATE DEMOCRATS BUDGET
PLAN- THIS OF PROGRAMS YOU
REQUIRE WOULD RECEIVE AN
ADDITIONAL ONE AND A HALF
BILLION DOLLARS IN ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND. BRINGING THE TOTAL
APPROPRIATION FOR THIS PROGRAM
TO THREE AND A HALF THEN. THE
ADDITIONAL ONE AND A HALF
BILLION WOULD BE ALLOCATED
EVENLY ACROSS THE THREE SEGMENTS
SO THAT WOULD BE FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION EACH TO UCCS. COLLEGES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NOW WE'RE GONNA MOVED OF THREE
SEGMENTS WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN
WITH THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. MMHM GOOD MORNING
CHAIR LAYERED. AND A SENATOR-
MEN THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME HERE
TODAY I'M SAY OVER TEN
REPRESENTING TO UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA VIEW STUDENT HOUSING
IS A KEY COMPONENT OF AN
AFFORDABLE EDUCATION. ACCESS TO
SAFE AFFORDABLE HOUSING ALLOWS
STUDENTS TO FOCUS ON THEIR
EDUCATIONAL GOALS. THE
AVAILABILITY OF CAMPUS HOUSING
PROVIDES STUDENTS WITH OPTIONS
OF WHERE TO LIVE. AND
ADDITIONALLY THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA HAS FOUND A LINK
BETWEEN STUDENT RETENTION AND
THE AVAILABLE THE OF CAMPUS
HOUSING FOR FIRST YEAR STUDENTS.
AS MANY OF OUR CAMPUSES ARE
LOCATED IN HIGH COST RENTAL
MARKETS IN TWENTY SIXTEEN THE
UNIVERSITY LAUNCHED THE STUDENT
HOUSING INITIATIVE. TO EXPAND
CAMPUS HOUSING CAPACITY THE
INITIATIVE AIMS TO PROVIDE AN
ADDITIONAL FOURTEEN THOUSAND NEW
AFFORDABLE CAMPUS HOUSING BEDS
BY TWENTY TWENTY. THE INITIATIVE
WAS VERY SUCCESSFUL AND BY FALL
TWENTY TWENTY ONE EXCEEDED THE
TARGET TO PROVIDE TWENTY ONE
THOUSAND NEW FENCE AS MEASURED
FROM TWENTY SIXTEEN. CAMPUSES
ARE PLANNING TO CONTINUE TO
EXPAND THE AVAILABILITY OF
STUDENT HOUSING AND CONSTRUCT AT
LEAST TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND NEW
STUDENT HOUSING BEDS OVER THE
NEXT FIVE YEARS. THE HIGHER
EDUCATION STUDENT HOUSING GRANT
PROGRAM CREATED BY THE
LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR WILL
PROVIDE STATE FUNDING FOR
AFFORDABLE STUDENT HOUSING
CONSTRUCTION. THESE GRANT FUNDS
WILL ASSIST IN KEEPING PROJECT
THAT TO A MINIMUM AND OFFERING
MORE LOW INCOME STUDENTS
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT CAMPUS
HOUSING OPTIONS. THE HIGHER
EDUCATION STUDENT HOUSING GRANT
PROGRAM WAS SIGNED BY THE
GOVERNOR ON SEPTEMBER TWENTY
THIRD TWENTY TWENTY ONE. AND THE
FIRST APPLICATIONS WERE DUE
OCTOBER THIRTY FIRST DESPITE
THIS TIGHT TURNAROUND SIX UC
CAMPUSES APPLY FOR FUNDING THE
SIX PROJECTS REQUESTED A TOTAL
OF SIX HUNDRED MILLION IN STATE TO CONSTRUCT. OVER THREE
THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED NEW
STUDENT BEDS. WHEN SENDING THESE
PROJECT DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
UNIVERSITY RANKED THEM BASED ON
STATE COSTS FOR BAD. I WANT TO
THANK THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
FOR THE REVIEW OF THESE PROJECTS
AND REQUEST THAT THE LEGISLATURE
APPROVED THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA PROJECTS THAT WERE
RECOMMENDED. THESE INCLUDE THE
THIRTY FIVE MILLION FOR UCLA TO
CONSTRUCT THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
EIGHT BEDS THE PROJECT WILL HAVE
A CAMPUS MATCH OF TWENTY EIGHT
POINT FIVE MILLION. AND THE
ANTICIPATED OCCUPANCY WOULD BE
FALL TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. AND ONE
HUNDRED MILLION FOR UC SAN DIEGO
TO CONSTRUCT ONE THOUSAND THREE
HUNDRED EIGHT TRANSFER STUDENT
BEDS. THIS PROJECT WILL HAVE A
CAMPUS MATCH OF TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY FIVE POINT FIVE MILLION.
AND YOU ANTICIPATED OCCUPANCY
WOULD BE FALL TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR. AND IN ADDITION UC MERCED
JOINTLY WITH MERCED COMMUNITY
COLLEGE RECEIVED A PLANNING
GRANT FOR FIVE HUNDRED. SIXTY
FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS. I WANT TO
THANK THE SENATE FOR PROPOSING
TO ACCELERATE THE FUNDING FOR
THE HIGHER EDUCATION STUDENT
HOUSING GRANT PROGRAM. BY
FUNDING MORE PROJECTS NOW THE
SENATE WILL HELP KEEP INFLATION
DRONE PROJECT COSTS DOWN AND
ENSURE THAT NEW STUDENT HOUSING
IS AVAILABLE A YEAR OR MORE
SOONER. THAN UNDER THE
ORIGINALLY PROPOSED THREE YEAR
FUNDING PLAN. BY STATUTE UC'S
ELIGIBLE 420% OF THE GRANT.
PROGRAM FUNDS WHICH UNDER THE
SENATE LAND OF THREE PER FIVE.
WOOD TOTALS HUNDRED MILLION FOR
YOU SEE. AS YOU CONSIDER THE
PROPOSALS THE FUN TO UNIVERSITY
REQUEST THAT CAMPUSES THAT WERE
PREVIOUSLY FOUND INELIGIBLE FOR
FUNDING. BE ALLOWED TO REVISE
AND RESUBMIT THEIR APPLICATIONS
WE WOULD ALSO LIKE FOR CAMPUSES
THAT MISSED THE LAST APPLICATION
CYCLE YOU HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
SUBMIT PROPOSALS. IN ADDITION WE
REQUEST THAT YOU RECONSIDER THE
MAXIMUM RENT ALLOWED FORMULA.
WHICH UNFORTUNATELY UP ONE THIRD
OF ONE HALF OF THE MEDIAN INCOME
IS SO LOW IN LOW INCOME AREAS AS
NOT TO COVER THE COST OF
CLEANING AND MAINTENANCE FOR THE
FACILITIES. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME TODAY. THANK YOU. ARE WILL
MOVE ON TO THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. GOOD
MORNING SENATOR LAYER TO MEMBERS
OF THE BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FIRST AND
FOREMOST FOR YOUR COMMITMENT TO
AFFORDABLE STUDENT HOUSING WE
ARE VERY GLAD TO SEE THE SENATE
PRIORITIES INCLUDE AN INCREASE
OF ONE POINT FIVE BILLION FOR A
MORE GRANTS FOR AFFORDABLE
STUDENT HOUSING. THE CALIFORNIA
COMING COLLEGES ALONG WITH MANY
DISTRICTS ACROSS THE STATE
SUPPORT- FULL FUNDING FOR THE
PROPOSED END ELIGIBLE PROJECTS
FUNDING FOR A PROPOSED AN
ELIGIBLE PROJECTS THAT HAVE BEEN
SUBMITTED TO YOU WHEN- MORE THAN
DOUBLE THE AVAILABLE STUDENT
HOUSING ACROSS OUR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES- ACROSS THESE
PROJECTS WE SEE A COMMITMENT TO
AFFORDABILITY. AND ON THE
COMMITMENT TO AFFORDABILITY IS
KEY TO CALIFORNIA'S COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AS A NEW INTO THE
HOUSING SPACE AND MANY COLLEGES
ARE BUILDING THIS CAPACITY- BUT
WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT. THE BILL
THIS CAPACITY IT'S FOR PURPOSES
OF ADDRESSING THE TOTAL COST OF
ATTENDANCE AND THE NEED THAT WE
SEE GROWING ACROSS OUR
COMMUNITIES ON WITH OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WE KNOW THAT
HOMELESSNESS IS ON THE RISE
SPACE NEEDS ARE ALSO ON THE RISE
AND HOUSING IS AN INTENTIONAL
STRATEGY TO ADDRESS THOSE. IN
TANDEM WITH OTHER EFFORTS TO
INCREASE CAL GRANT AND OTHER KEY
RESOURCES THAT HIDE WITH
AFFECTED STUDENTS SUPPORTS AND A
COMMITMENT TO SUCCESS IN
ENSURING THAT WE ARE REPEATING
EDUCATIONAL OUTCOMES OR
CALIFORNIA AND REACHING THE
PROPOSED 70% GOAL OF ADULTS
EARNING DEGREES OR CREDENTIALS.
LET ME TELL YOU A LITTLE BIT
MORE ABOUT THESE PROJECTS SOME
OF THE PROJECTS THAT ARE
PROPOSED AND ELIGIBLE- IN ON
THIS YEAR'S GRANTS ARE ONES THAT
ARE IN FIREAFFECTED AREAS.
THREE AND FACTOR FROM FIRE
AFFECTED AREAS WHERE NOT ONLY
HAVE HOUSING COSTS REASON.
THEY'VE ALSO- IN OF. THE ACT THE
- OTHERS AREN'T AREA WHERE- IT'S
HARD OR DIFFICULT OR EXPENSIVE
TO CONSTRUCT AND THEREFORETHAT
TENDS TO DRIVE COSTS FOR
STUDENTS. MANY OF THESE PROJECTS
THAT YOU SEE BEFORE YOU ARE IN
REGIONS WHERE IT THE RENTAL
COSTS ARE ANYWHERE FROM.
NINETEEN HUNDRED TO TWENTY FOUR
HUNDRED DOLLARS FOR A ONE
BEDROOM MAKING IT UNAFFORDABLE
FOR A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS. SO AGAIN WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COMMITMENT TO
AFFORDABLE SKIN HOUSING THE
CALIFORNIA COMING COLLEGES HAS
LAUNCHED A TASK FORCE TO BUILD
THE INFRASTRUCTURE ADDRESS
REGULATION CHANGES COLLECTED
DATA NECESSARY SO THAT WE CAN
SUPPORT THESE COLLEGES. AS THE
BUILT IN THIS NEW STRATEGY IN
THESE PROGRAMS LOCALLY SO THEY
CAN BE PER ARE SUPPORTED WITH
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE- AND HE
SUPPORT INTO THAT ARE
REGULATIONS ALSO ALIGNED WITH
THE DIRECTION THAT THE
LEGISLATURE ONCE THE CAKE. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COMMITMENT- AND
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND LET ME
NOTE FOR THE RECORD WE'VE BEEN
JOINED BY SENATOR JOE BOB WE
HAVE A FULL COMMITTEE RIGHT NOW.
AND WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO THE
LAST OF THE PRESENTERS ON ISSUE
TWENTY TWO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY EAST. GET YOUR LETTER
GOOD MORNING COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS FIVE SEVEN ONE IN THE
SYSTEM VICE CHANCELLOR FOR
CAPITAL PLANNING DESIGNING
CONSTRUCTION FOR THE CSU
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. SINCE YOU
SUBMITTED TO COMMITTEE STAFF THE
FUNDING REQUEST FOR THE GRANT
PROGRAM. ALONG WITH PROPOSED
TRAILER BILL REVISIONS THE- FOR
THE COMMITTEE'S CONSIDERATION.
THE CSU ATHLETIC THE LEGISLATURE
TO APPROVE FUNDING. OF ABOUT
FOUR HUNDRED AND FORTY MILLION.
FOR THE FIRST TWO OF THE TWO
BILLION DOLLAR MULTI YOUR BILL.
SO IF THE SENATE IS SUCCESSFUL
IN THE WORLD TO WORK PROGRAM WE
NEED TO BE HAPPY JUST SUBMIT AN
ADDITIONAL CYCLE PROJECTS. CAN
SAY THIS FALL. FOUR HUNDRED AND
FORTY MILLION PROJECTS IS
COMPRISED OF SPENDING FOR SEVEN
NEW PROJECTS AND FIFTY MILLION
TO BEGIN THE DIRECT HOUSING
GRANT PROGRAM FOR LOW INCOME
STUDENTS. WITH REGARD TO THE
PROJECT FUNDING REQUESTS THE
PROJECTS INCLUDE TO RECOMMENDED
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
HELLO WITH FIVE ADDITIONAL
PROJECTS THAT WERE DEEMED
ELIGIBLE. BUT BASED ON THE
TRUSTEES PRIORITIES. ACROSS THE
SEVEN PROJECTS THE CSU PROPOSES
TO CONSTRUCT TWO THOUSAND TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTY SIX AFFORDABLE
BEST INCREASED CAPACITY. TO COPE
FUND PROJECTS USING CSU BOND
FINANCING OF TWO HUNDRED SIX
MILLION. THE CSU CO FUNDING. THE
COST PER BED TO THE STATE BY
ABOUT FIFTY SEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER BED. AND HELPS TO
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF BELOW
MARKET RATE THAT STORE STUDENTS.
WITH THE EXCEPTION OF THE INTER
SEGMENTAL PROJECT WITHIN
PRIVILEGED COMMUNITY COLLEGE WE
PROPOSED 65% STATE GRANT FUNDS
AND 35% CSU CO FOUNDING. THE LA-
IS CORRECT THAT THESE PROJECTS
COME WITH RISKS IN EXTREME
CONSTRUCTION COST ESCALATION. IS
AN ONGOING CONCERN. THE SENATE'S
WEALTH TO WORK PROPOSAL TO
INCREASE PROGRAM SPENDING IS AN
OPPORTUNITY. FOR THE SEGMENTS TO
DELIVER THE PROJECT GIVEN THE
UNPRECEDENTED ESCALATION IT
CONTINUES. THE PROPOSED TRAILER
BILL COULD BE FASHION TO
INCLUDING NOTICE PROVISION OR
FOR THE SPOKE WITH BUDGET CHANGE
BUT ALSO ENABLE THE CSU TO
MANAGE ESCALATION WITH IT WITHIN
ITS TARGETED EMAIL. WHICH IS
CURRENTLY SIX HUNDRED MILLION.
THAT COULD INCREASE ONE POINT
ONE BILL WITH THE SAN PROPOSE.
FOR THE PROJECT PURCHASE STATION
IN ADDITION TO THE FACTORS
CONSIDERED BY PARTNERS FINANCES
CSU ALSO CONSIDERED PERCENTAGE
OF LOW INCOME STUDENTS. THE
CONSTRUCTION START DATE AND THE
AMOUNT OF EXISTING BEDS FOR
CAMPUS. FRESNO STATE FOR EXAMPLE
HAS ONLY 5% OF BETS TO SERVICE
STUDENT POPULATION. GIVEN THE
DESIRED START DATE IN THE
STATUTE IN THE STATUTE OF
DECEMBER TWENTY TWO. CSU HAS
STARTED THE PROCUREMENT PROCESS
FOR DESIGNING CONSTRUCTION FOR A
NUMBER OF THE PRIORITY PROJECTS
AND YOUR SUPPORT WOULD ENABLE
THESE PROJECTS TO CONTINUE AT
PACE. FOR SUGGESTIONS GOING
FORWARD TO SEE IF YOU PROPOSES
THE STATUTE BE BROADENED TO
INCLUDE. FLEXIBILITY TO ALLOW
FOR RENOVATIONS WHERE WE CAN
INCREASE THE DENSITY GOING FROM
TWO BEDS IN A ROOM TO THREE BEDS
THAT WILL REDUCE THE COST
PREVENT VERSUS NEW CONSTRUCTION.
AND AN IDEA THAT WOULD PERMIT
CSU TO USE HER AS A PART OF ITS
TARGETED FUNDS PROVIDE HOUSING
GRANTS DIRECTLY TO STUDENTS IF
ALLOWED THE RENOVATION PROJECTS
COULD BE SUBMITTED. FOR TWENTY
TO TWENTY TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR THE THIRD YEAR PRO OF THE
PROGRAM. IN THE GRANT DOLLARS BE
USED TO ADDRESS STATE FARM
MARSHALL REQUIREMENTS FOR
EXITING FIRE SPRINKLERS FIRE
ALARMS. BUT ALSO OTHER UPGRADES
THAT WE ARE REQUIRED BY CODE. SO
PROJECTS THAT WOULD INCREASE
DENSITY MCCARTY USE FOR CSU
SHOULD THE RENOVATIONS BE
ALLOWED. THE SECOND REQUESTING
TO THE STATUTE WOULD ALLOW
PORTION OF THE FUNDS BE USED FOR
A- DIRECT GRANT TO STUDENTS THAT
WOULD REDUCE THE COST OF
HOUSING. THE CSU ASKED FOR FIFTY
MILLION BE APPROVED EFFECTIVE SO
THE BEDS COULD BE OFFERED
AVAILABLE BEDS COULD BE OFFERED
TO LOOK IN STUDENTS AT THE RATE
DEFINED IN THE STATUTE. THE CSU
WOULD SET UP TYPE OF IN DOWN
MEANT TO USE THE FUNDS OVER TIME
WITH TWENTY TO THIRTY YEARS BE
THE GOAL THEN WE WOULD USE THE
AMOUNT OF. PROCEEDS AND EARNED
BY THE INVESTMENT TO. SUBSIDIZE
THE COST TO LOOKING STUDENTS THE
PROJECT COULD BE IMPLEMENTED IN
A MATTER OF MONTHS VERSES
ROUGHLY THREE TO FOUR YEARS FOR
NEW CONSTRUCTION. THIS APPROACH
WOULD CRITICS WIDGET NOT EXPOSE
THE PROGRAM TO BE CONTINUED
CONSTRUCTION COST ESCALATION AS
A CAMPUSES WITH AVAILABLE BEDS
COULD PURCHASE MADE IMMEDIATELY
SO IT'S FASTER. IT INCREASES THE
AMOUNT OF PORTABLE HOUSING
SUPPORTS IT RENDITION OF
BALANCES OUT THE BILL ABILITY
AND AFFORDABILITY SO IN SUMMARY
THE CSU REQUEST IS FOR FOUR
HUNDRED AND FORTY MILLION OR
COMBINATION PROJECTS AND A NEW
DIRECT STUDENT GRANT SUBSIDY.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
OF THE EVIDENCE GATHERING
QUESTIONS THANK YOU THAT
COMPLETES OUR FIVE PRESENTATIONS
AND WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO THE
COMMITTEE. COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS. AND LET ME BEGIN. OF
BY JUST MAKING A COUPLE OF
COMMENTS OBVIOUSLY- OF THE TWO
BILLION DOLLARS THAT WAS
APPROPRIATED LAST YEAR FOR THIS
PURPOSE OVER THREE YEARS WAS
OVERSUBSCRIBED AND- INDICATED A
DRAMATIC NEED. AND SO THAT IS
WHY. OF THERE HAS BEEN A
PROPOSAL FROM- THE SENATE
MAJORITY TO ADD ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION ODD TO TRY. TO ADDRESS
THAT NEED. IS WHAT WE ARE HERE
TODAY- SECOND. I KNOW THAT PROBE
WAS REALLY QUICKLY BY THE- AFTER
IT WAS APPROVED AND THAT DID NOT
BEEN IN PLACE BEFORE. AND I
THINK OCCASIONALLY THERE WERE
SOME THINGS LOST IN THE
TRANSLATION AND I KNOW THAT WHEN
THE GRANTS WENT OUT. IT WAS NOT
MADE CLEAR THAT. HE LANDING IN
CONSTRUCTION GRANTS TOGETHER FOR
THE SAME PROJECT WOULD NOT BE
ALLOWED TO NEARBY I KNOW IT WAS
ONE PLACE IN MY DISTRICT DID
THAT DID THEY WERE REALLY
DISAPPOINTED. BECAUSE THAT
WASN'T LAID OUT IN ADVANCE WITH
CLARITY AND SO I WOULD JUST
REITERATE. THAT IT'S GOOD TO BE
REALLY CLEAR ABOUT WHAT THE
EXPECTATION IS FROM THE
APPLICANTS SO THAT THEY CAN
RESPOND IN AN APPROPRIATE WAY.
AND- THEN. LET ME MOVE TO A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS BEFORE I GO
TO MY COLLEAGUES AND THE FIRST
ONE IS- TO THE THREE BRANCHES-
WE HEARD IN THE PRESENTATION AND
IN A MORE DETAILED WRITTEN
PRESENTATION AT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S RESPONDED TO THIS
PROGRAM. WEST OF THREE PRIMARY
RECOMMENDATIONS BUT OTHER
FEEDBACK I WOULD ASK. EACH OF
THE BRANCHES IF THEY WOULD
RESPOND TO THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S ANALYSIS WHAT THEIR
THOUGHTS ARE ABOUT IT AND LET'S
GO ON THE SAME ORDER THAT THE
PRESENTATION WAS SO LET'S BEGIN
WITH THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU CENTER
LETTERED- THE L. A. O. WHO HAD.
ONE OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS WAS
TO HAVE THE OF INSTITUTIONS
PROVIDE A CONTINGENCY FUND FROM
NON STATE FUNDS. OF WE CAN MAKE
THAT HAPPEN WE CAN BUILD THAT
INTO THE PLANNING PROCESS. FOR
ALL OF OUR CAMPUSES THAT RECEIVE
FUNDING UNDER DISCREPANCIES SO
THEY ARE PREPARED TO GUARANTEE-
OF 10% CONTINGENCY OR SOME
AMOUNT OF CONTINGENCY FROM
NONSTATE FUNDS TOWARD THE
PROJECT- THIS MAY BE NECESSARY
RIGHT NOW AS OUR INFLATION IS
DRIVING UP CONSTRUCTION COSTS
QUITE RAPIDLY- AND IT OFTEN
TAKES OVER YEAR. TO CONSTRUCT
ONE OF THESE PROJECTS SO- VERY
LIKELY WE WILL SEE COST
ESCALATION EVEN ASK CONSTRUCTION
IS HAPPENING. THEN THE L. A.
O.'S- OTHER RECOMMENDATIONS OF
ME- SO IN TERMS OF HAVING DE UM
. INSTITUTION COME BACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE WHEN THERE IS A
CHANGE IN THE NUMBER OF
AFFORDABLE BEDS IN THE PROJECT I
THINK THAT IS COMPLETELY
REASONABLE- WE DO WANT TO
CAUTION YOU AGAINST HAVING THE
INSTITUTION COME BACK FOR
NEEDING TO USE MORE OF NEEDING
TO USE SOME OF THE CONTINGENCY
FUNDS. OF THAT THEY WILL PUT
FORWARD BECAUSE OF THAT IS VERY
LIKELY TO OCCUR AND THE THIRTY
DAY NOTICE WILL CAUSE ADDITIONAL
DELAYS IN THE PROJECT- IN ORDER
TO HAVE A STUDENT HOUSING
PROJECT SERVE THE MOST STUDENTS
IT REALLY NEEDS TO OPEN IN THE
FALL SO WE CAN FULLY FILLED OUT
PROJECT- AND ANY KIND OF DELAYS
COULD PUSH THAT OPENING DATE
BACK SO WE WANT TO JUST CAUTION
YOU ABOUT. THE COST OVERRUNS AND
HOW FREQUENTLY A CAMPUS WOULD
NEED TO COME BACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU LET'S MOVE ON TO THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE. MORNING AGAIN WAS THAT
NUMBER AT- SECTOR MY SCENES WITH
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES WHEN WE ADDRESS SOME OF
THE KEY POINTS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE MENTIONED THE FIRST
ALL TALK ABOUT AND REYES RELATED
TO DATA- AND THE ABILITY TO
MONITOR THESE PROJECTS. THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE SOME IN
COLLABORATION WITH THE BOARD OF
GOVERNORS AND KEY STAKEHOLDERS
IS UNDERTAKING EXTENSIVE WORK TO
INTEGRATE HOUSING PROJECTS- AND
HOUSING PLANS INTO PLATFORM WE
HAVE A COLD FUSION SO THAT WE
HAVE DATA ACCESSIBLE TO USE SO
THAT YOU CAN MONITOR PROGRESS.
AND WE CAN- ENSURING THAT
THERE'S ACCOUNTABILITY THAT
ELEMENTS WILL ALSO- WE'RE
INTEGRATING A LOOKING AT TOTAL
COST OF OWNERSHIP WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THESE PROJECTS
HAVE LONG TERM QUALITY AND CAN
BE SUSTAINABLE IN TERMS OF
COSTS. AND WE KNOW THAT BUILDING
IS NOT THE ONLY COSTS THE
COLLEGES ARE COMMITTING TO IT'S
REALLY UP HE AND THE SERVICES
AND HE SUPPORTS THAT ARE OFFERED
TO STUDENTS THAT ARE VALUABLE SO
WE DO THINK THAT THAT IS AN
IMPORTANT ELEMENT. AND THE
TEAMSTERS OFFICE IS READY TO
SUPPORT NETWORK- WITHIN THE-
LAST OVER RUN ON BREAKING. THAT
THE- PRICE YOU. INCLUDE PERCENT
- ORIGINAL FOR A BUFFERING
CUSTOMER RENDON DO THINK THAT-
CONSIDERING A SLIGHT ADJUSTMENT
TO THAT IS IMPORTANT- AND THEN
AND HOLDING THE LINE THERE SO
THAT COLLEGES ARE COMMITTED AND-
CAN PROVE THAT THEY CAN SUSTAIN
THIS AGAIN. WE'RE NOT LOOKING AT
JUST THE COSTS NOW BUT THERE ARE
LONG TERM- ABILITY TO AFFORD
THESE PROJECTS. WITH REGARDS TO
GENERAL AFFORDABILITY IN TERMS
OF SETTING RENTS ONE OF THE KEY
ELEMENTS THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT-
IS PROVIDING GUIDANCE TO
COLLEGES- AND HOW TO DECIDE WHO-
AND PROVIDING SOME TEMPLATE ON
HOW TO DECIDE. WHO TO- PROVIDE
HOUSING TO GIVEN THAT EVEN
LOCALLY- SOME OF THE SOUND BEDS
WILL BE OVERSUBSCRIBED. AND SO
WE'RE LOOKING AT THE- EXPECTED
FAMILY CONTRIBUTION AS ONE OF
THE FACTORS THIS LOOKS I-
AFFORDABILITY MEASURES THAT ARE
MORE IN LINE WITH SOME OF THE
FINANCIAL AID DATA THAT
COLLEGES. COLLECTED LOCALLY SO
THAT THOSE SOME OF THE KEY
PIECES THAT REALLY STAND OUT TO
US I'M FROM THE ALLEY ANALYSIS
HAPPY TO GO INTO MORE DETAILS
THERE ARE OTHER SPECIFIC ONES
THAT YOU'RE INTERESTED IN. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NOW WILL MOVE ON.
TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM. IT THE UC AN
MANY COLLEGE IN THE A. O.
RECOGNIZE THE- AS. ALSO THE
BENEFITS. WE BUILT IN A 5%
ESCALATION FOR US PER YEAR GOING
OUT TO THE MIDPOINT AND WE'VE
HAD 10% ESCALATION IN THE FIRST
FEW MONTHS OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO
ALONE SO WE'RE WE'RE RAN ABOUT
20% SINCE WE HAVE DEVELOPED
THESE PROPOSALS IF NOT A LITTLE
BIT HIGHER THAT IS A CONCERN AND
I THINK THE ALEJO'S FORTY DONE
THE FLEXIBILITY THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS ON HOW THE
PROGRAM IS DEVELOPED AS WE GO
FORWARD IS ALSO KEY AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO THAT THE BILL THE FOR
THE LEGISLATURE TO MOLD A
PROGRAM. TO ADDRESS
AFFORDABILITY BECAUSE THE LOW
INCOME STUDENTS IS NOTED ON PAGE
EIGHTEEN STILL HAVE UNMET
FINANCIAL NEED SO WE'RE
PROPOSING A PROCESS WHERE WITH
THIS GRANT WE COULD HIT A NUMBER
OF CAMPUSES ACROSS THE SYSTEM
AND NOT JUST LIMITED TO SEVEN
EIGHT NINE CAMPUSES SO WE ARE
EXPECTING CAMPUS HOUSING PLANS
TO COME IN THE NEXT MONTH OR SO
THERE DUE TO THE LEGISLATURE
JULY FIRST AND SO HAVING. SOME
DOLLARS TO PROVIDE SUPPORT THEIR
EFFORTS TO PROVIDE EMERGENCY
HOUSING AND LOW INCOME HOUSING
WILL BE REALLY VERY VERY
BENEFICIAL TO SUPPORT THEIR
HOUSING PLANTS THE OTHER ITEM ON
ITEM VETO PAGE EIGHTEEN IS JUST
LIKE YOUR FACIAL. ISSUES ON
ACADEMIC PROJECTS SO WE
APPRECIATE THAT THERE'S BEEN
INCREASED DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
AND CAPITAL FUNDING FOR A
PROPOSED IN THE SENATE PLAN-
SEVENTY THREE QUESTIONS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND NOW
LET ME. ASK OF THE DEPART OF
FINE IN THE LEAD. AND WHO REESE.
TO THE COMMENTS. OF THE THREE
SEGMENTS AND IN PARTICULAR- THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SAID
THAT ONE PARTICULAR METRIC WAS
SO LOW THAT THEY COULDN'T DO.
MAINTENANCE AND ONGOING COSTS
BECAUSE OF THAT METRIC AND THAT
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM- ASKED ABOUT A POSSIBLE
GRANT PROGRAM AND I RECOGNIZE
THAT. THAT WE HAVE THREADED THE
NEEDLE HERE BETWEEN ONE TIME AND
ONGOING FUNDS AND THEY'RE ASKING
FOR ON GOING FUNDS TO SUPPORT A
ONE TIME FUND ALLOCATION OF FOR
HOUSING. BUT LET'S ASK THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYSTS TO RESPOND
TO ANYTHING THEY HEARD FROM THIS
THREE SEGMENTS BUT WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IN
PARTICULAR TO THOSE TWO SPECIFIC
CONCERNS. AND LET'S BEGIN WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. A
DIFFICULT- WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE I'M SO TO SPEAK- TO
THE UC'S OF COMMENTS ON THE
RENT- OUR MAIN GOAL WITH THIS
PROPOSAL WAS TO REALLY PROVIDE
THE LOWEST MOST AFFORDABLE RENT
TO STUDENTS- AND WE'VE FOUND
THROUGH THE UC'S APPLICATIONS
THAT- AT LEAST TO THE
APPLICATIONS THAT WE REVIEWED
AND THEY SUBMITTED- THAT THEY
WERE ABLE TO PROVIDE-
MAINTENANCE TO THEIR FACILITY
SEEP THROUGH THE RENT THAT THEY
HAVE. TO THE RIGHT THAT WE
PROPOSE AND THEY HAVE PROPOSED
IN THEIR APPLICATIONS- SO- AND
THEN IN TERMS OF WE CAN'T REALLY
SPEAK TO ANY- FUTURE PROPOSALS
AT THIS TIME AND AS WE HAVEN'T
REVIEWED WE HAVEN'T HAD THE TIME
TO REVIEW THAT SO I CAN'T
SPECIFICALLY COMMENT ON ANY
ONGOING FUNDING OR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE SPENDING AT THIS
TIME- SO YEAH. THANK YOU. DO YOU
HAVE ANY OTHER COMMENTS ON THE
OF THE CSU. ON GOING PROPOSAL
AND ANYTHING ELSE THAT THEY SAID
IN RESPONSE TO THE OHIO. THAT'S
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- SO
AT THIS TIME WE HAVEN'T REVIEWED
ANY PROPOSALS THAT THAT THE CSU
HAS WE CAN'T REALLY SPEAK ON ANY
PROPOSALS THAT THE CSU HAS
SUBMITTED TO US- CAN YOU. BE
MORE SPECIFIC IN TERMS OF- WHAT
WHAT THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST
SAID OUT. HERE HERE YOU CAN'T
RESPOND TO THE CSU WON THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S SET OUT
THREE DIFFERENT THINGS THAT THEY
THOUGHT WOULD BE IMPROVEMENTS TO
THE HOUSING PROGRAM IN THE THREE
BRANCHES JUST RESPONDED AND I'M
ASKING IF YOU WANT TO RESPOND.
TO THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST ON
THOSE THREE DIFFERENT THINGS OR
ANYTHING THAT THE BRANCHES SAID.
WITH THEIR RESPONSE TO. YEAH SO-
TO SPEAK SPECIFICALLY ON THE
CASE THE POINT OF THE
CONTINGENCY WE ACTUALLY DID
PROVIDE A 10% CONTINGENCY TO ALL
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND THEN FOR
THE FROM THE UC IN THE CSU THEY
DID BUILT IN A 5% CONTINGENCY.
INTO EACH OF THEIR PROJECT
PROPOSALS- SO THAT THAT'S FOR
ONE AND THEN ADDITIONALLY JUST%
TO KIND OF GO INTO OUR THOUGHT
PROCESS AND THE WAY THAT WE
HAVE. SELECTED PROJECTS AS WE
REALLY FOLLOWED- WHAT WAS
REQUIRED IN STATUTE- YOUKNOW
FOR EXAMPLE THE REQUIRED FRANK
ACOSTA- AS WELL AS YOU KNOW
CERTAIN STUDENT METRICS OUR
REQUIRED- AND THEN WE KIND OF WE
WEEDED OUT PROJECTS BASED ON
THAT INITIALLY AND THEN WE WENT
INTO RANKING PROJECTS BASED ON.
THE CONSTRUCTION COSTS WHICH WAS
REALLY AN EFFICIENCY METRICS AS
WELL AS THE STUDENT RIGHT COST
WHICH WAS- IN AFFORDABILITY
METRICS- AND THROUGH THAT
ANALYSIS WE FOUND THAT THAT WAS
ACTUALLY THE BEST WAY TO. TO
RANK PROJECTS AGAINST EACH OTHER
BECAUSE THAT WAS THE MORE
UNIVERSAL AND METRIC THAT COULD
BE COMPATIBLE AGAINST DIFFERENT
PROJECTS AND I WAS REALLY OUR
THOUGHT PROCESS BEHIND- WHAT
WHAT WE PUT FORWARD. TO THE
LEGISLATURE- AND HAPPY DANCE ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU LET ME ASK.
THE L. A. O. IF IN THIS ROUND
ROBIN YOU HAVE BEEN THE LAST
COMMENT ON WHAT YOU HEARD FROM
THE DIFFERENT BRANCHES OR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. SURE SO-
I YOU KNOW WE HAVE BEEN
RELEASED- ANYTHING'S ARE ANY
ANALYSIS SPECIFICALLY ON- A LOT
OF THAT POINTS THAT WERE RAISED
HERE SO- YOU KNOW WE'D BE HAPPY
TO WORK WITH STAFF IN THE COMING
WEEKS ON ANY ITEMS OF PARTICULAR
INTEREST ON THE USED TO COMMENT
ON THE STATURE RANCH IS A BIG
LEAP. FROM IN OUR ANALYSIS WE
RAISED- SOME POINTS TO CONSIDER
AROUND THE PROPOSED STATUTORY
RENTS- OUR- OUR POINT WAS A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT I THINK
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE- YOU KNOW
THE STATUTORY WRENCH THAT THAT
MEASURE. 30% OR 50% OF ANY AREAS
NEEDING INCOME. AS A COMMON
MEASURE USED IN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PROGRAMS. WITHIN THE
COLLEGE CONTEXT IS A LITTLE
DIFFICULT TO TRANSLATE. THAT'S
BECAUSE A LOT OF STUDENTS
PARTICULARLY AT UC AND CSU. ARE
IT DEPENDENCE AND THEIR
HOUSEHOLDS ARE ALREADY SPENDING
A PORTION OF THEIR INCOME. ON
THEIR PRIMARY RESIDENCE AND SO
THEY LIKELY COULD NOT IN
CONCEPTS ALSO DEVOTING
ADDITIONAL 30% OF THEIR ANNUAL
INCOME TO SUPPORT HOUSING FOR
THEIR COLLEGE STUDENT.
INTERNALLY SPEAKING THE WAY WE
THINK ABOUT FINANCIAL AID IS
VERY DIFFERENT IT OFTEN SEEMS
STUDENTS AND THEIR HOUSEHOLD
SAVE MONEY OVER TIME WORK PART
TIME. IT'S BASED ON THE SORT OF
EXPECTED FAMILY CONTRIBUTION AND
FINANCIAL NEED. AND SO WE DID
ENCOURAGE LEGISLATURE OVER THE
COMING YEARS TO THINK ABOUT WAYS
TO SORT OF INTEGRATE FINANCIAL
AID. AND STUDENT HOUSING COSTS
AS IT AS A SORT OF PROCEDURES
PROGRAM MOVING FORWARD- AS IN
TERMS OF THE ISSUES OF. UP ON
START HAVING A SEPARATE PROGRAM
. IN THAT IT STATE SEES YOU
SUSPENDED US ALL. WITH ALL.
PROPOSALS IN THE EVEN TO SOME
SOME MENTAL AND ON ON ITS CAN WE
BE TO WORK STAFF ON THAT-
THERE'S OF THOSE ITEMS OF.
INTEREST I'M FINALLY I DID HEAR
SOME- POINTS AROUND WHATEVER
RECOMMENDATIONS WHICH INVOLVES-
THE NOTIFICATION PROCESS AND
JUST INSURING WHAT'S NOT. YOUR
TO ARRESTS FOR PROJECTS AND- ON
SOME OF THOSE THEM THE FEEDBACK
SOUNDS REASONABLE I THINK THERE
ARE WAYS WE CAN STRUCTURE THE
REPORTING LANGUAGE THAT JUST
SOME OF THOSE CONCERNS. YOU KNOW
FOR EXAMPLE WHEN I IN OUR
ANALYSIS WE RECOMMENDED. SETTING
AND- SORT OF MINIMUM THRESHOLD
OF LIKE 10% OF THE PROJECT
CHANGE SO THAT. REALLY MINOR
CHANGES DON'T REQUIRE OF YOUR
NOTIFICATION I THINK I THINK
THERE ARE OTHER WAYS TO BEGIN
CONSTRUCTION THAT'S ABOUT IT THE
JUSTICE SOME OF THE CONCERNS.
RAISED THANK YOU MANAHAN FROM C.
REPRESENTATIVE DO YOU A COMMENT
YOU WANT ME. THANK YOU CAN I
JUST WANTED CLARIFY THAT WE
SPEAKING CONGO BECAUSE FOR FROM
WE WOULD ARE ABOUT A PORTION OF
THE GRANT FUNDS THAT ARE IS
INCLUDED IN THE LEGISLATION.
THAT WE WOULD SET ASIDE AS AN
ENDOWMENT AND IT WOULD BE THE
EARNINGS FROM THE CORPUS OF
THAT. OF THE FIFTY MILLION THAT
WE WOULD USE TO SUBSIDIZE
HOUSING COSTS FOR STUDENTS IN SO
THAT WE WOULD HOPE TO SPEND LESS
THAN THE INTEREST EARNINGS ON
ANNUAL BASIS SO WE WOULD KEEP
THE CORPUS INTACT OVER TIME. IS
THE CLARIFICATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARMANI GO TO MY
COLLEAGUES. SORRY THAT WE HAD
THIS ANIMATED DISCUSSION START
WITH SENATOR MEN AND THEN. THANK
YOU CHAIRED AT APPRECIATE THE
DISCUSSION HERE AND YOU KNOW I
REPRESENT UC IRVINE AND A NUMBER
OF COMMUNITY COLLEGES I MY
DISTRICT- I AM ALWAYS DISTURBED
TO HEAR ABOUT THE HIGH
PERCENTAGE OF HOUSING IN SECURE
AND HOMELESS STUDENTS. OBVIOUSLY
IT IS DIFFICULT EXPECT OUR
STUDENTS TO DO WELL ACADEMICALLY
IF THEY'RE STRUGGLING TO FIGURE
OUT WHETHER TO SLEEP ANY GIVEN
NIGHT- SO I THINK IT'S AN
IMPORTANT DISCUSSION TO HAVE AND
I APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT BOTH
THE SENATE AND THE GOVERNOR'S
ADMINISTRATION ARE PRIORITIZING
THE CONSTRUCTION OF STUDENT
HOUSING HERE- BUT I DO HAVE A
FEW FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS. FIRST I
GUESS I WANTED TO. DRILL DOWN A
LITTLE BIT I GUESS THIS QUESTION
IS FOR BOTH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND THE L. A- AND ALSO
THE DIFFERENT DIVISIONS IF THEY
HAVE ANY COMMENTS BUT- TO WHAT
DEGREE IS THIS AN ISSUE OF A
LACK OF LOW INCOME OR LOWER COST
HOUSING THESE OF THE JUST.
OVERALL HOUSING SUPPLY BECAUSE
I'VE HEARD YEAH I MEAN ORANGE
COUNTY WE HAVE. BOTH A LACK OF
SUPPLY ANY LACK OF LOWER COST
SUPPLY. I'M JUST TRY TO FIGURE
OUT YOU KNOW IS THERE SOME
STUDENTS THEY AND I PLACES LIKE
UC IRVINE OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. THAT CAN CERTAINLY
AFFORD TO PAY FOR MARKET RATE
HOUSING. ARE THERE SOME STUDENTS
THAT YOU DON'T NEED SOME HELP
AND THEY NEED LOWER INCOME OR
LOWER COST HOUSING AND I'M
TRYING TO GET A SENSE OF IF
WE'VE- ANALYZED THIS ISSUE. AND
WHAT DEGREE E. INTO THIS IS.
THIS THE SAME FROM ARE FACING
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
RIGHT NOW THERE'S BOTH A LACK OF
SUPPLY. AND A LACK OF SUPPLY FOR
LOWER INCOME FAMILIES AND AGAIN
TRYING TO GET THAT SENSE SO IF
YOU HAVE. ANY COMMENTS OR
THOUGHTS I'D APPRECIATE HEARING
. LET'S START WITH THAT. L. SURE
SO I THINK- I THINK YOU RAISE A
KIND OF KEY CONSIDERING FOR THE
LARGEST WHICH YOU KNOW WHETHER
TO FOLK ON SORT OF OVER HOUSING
FOR COLLEGE OR WHETHER THE FOCUS
BE MORE ON THE FOR. AND OVERALL
CULTURE FOR AND AFFORDABILITY IN
FOR TWO- YOU KNOW CONSENT THE
PURPOSE OF THIS PROGRAM IN
PROVIDING STATE FUNDING FOR
HOUSING PROJECTS ARGUABLY IS. ON
AFFORDABILITY THAT'S BECAUSE
CAMPUSES HAVE LONG BEEN IT WAS
PARTICULARLY AT UC INTO ME AND
THE CSU SYSTEM. I'VE BEEN ABLE
TO FIND HOUSING PROJECTS FROM
HOUSING FEE REVENUE AND SO
CONCEPTUALLY THE AYE THE
ADVANTAGE OF PROVIDING STATE
FUNDING IS TO MAKE THESE AND
IT'S MORE AFFORDABLE.
SUMMARIZING A PORTION OF THE
COSTS HOSTER THAT THEY ARE
INTENDED RENTS CAN BE LOWER THAN
THE OTHERWISE WHAT HAPPENS. ONLY
WE DID LOOK AT THIS ISSUE IN THE
FALL AND THEN WE GENERALLY HEARD
FROM CAMPUSES THAT MANY OF THEM
WERE. ABLE TO CONSTRUCT A
STUDENT HOUSING THAT FROM
STUDENT FEE REVENUE OVER TIME.
AND SO AGAIN THAT THAT SEEM TO
SUGGEST AT LEAST THAT WASN'T
NECESSARILY A FUNDING ISSUE IN
TERMS OF INCREASING OVERALL
HOUSING SUPPLY. YOU KNOW THAT'S
A THERE ARE CASES WHERE CAMPUSES
DO-EXPERIENCES INSTANCE
INSTANCES WHERE THERE CAN BE SIR
TIGHTER HOUSING THE NORMAL-
WE'VE HEARD THAT AND I DON'T WE
FOR EXAMPLE IN THE UC MERCED
CAMPUS. AND THEN THERE ARE ALSO
CASES WHERE- YOU KNOW CAMPUS IS
A MOMENT. IT'S PAST THREE CAN
ALSO BE LIMITED BASED ON HOUSING
CAPACITY THAT RECENTLY CAME UP
WITH UC BERKELEY- THAT CERTAINLY
IS AN ISSUE TO THE LEGISLATURE
COULD THINK ABOUT THAT ARE YOU
KNOW AT LEAST. FROM OUR
UNDERSTANDING OF THE PRIMARY
VANTAGE OF PROVIDING A STATE
SUBSIDY FOR THIS PROJECT IS TO
MAKE THEM MORE AFFORDABLE. THANK
YOU- BERMAN FINANCE. JENNIFER
**** WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- YEAH WE YOU KNOW THERE
IS A BROADER- STATEWIDE HOUSING
CRISIS AND WE HAVE HEARD THROUGH
VARIOUS LEGISLATION ANECDOTALLY
FROM. YOU KNOW THE UNIVERSITIES
AND COLLEGES THAT THEIR STUDENTS
ARE GOING ON HOUSE OR LIVING IN
CARS- AND SO THIS PROPOSAL
REALLY AIMS TO ADDRESS ACTUALLY
BOTH OF THE ISSUES THAT YOU
MENTIONED. WHICH IS INCREASING
THE SUPPLY OF HOUSING AT THESE
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES AS
WELL AS PROVIDING MORE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING RIGHT BECAUSE
THE RENT IS CAPPED- TO PROVIDE
THE MOST AFFORDABLE RENT TO
STUDENTS. GOT IN AND I ASISTIR
BECAUSE- YOU KNOW IT'S BEEN A
WHILE A LONG TIME SINCE I WAS IN
COLLEGE OR OR IN GRAD SCHOOL-
BUT MY SENSE WAS. AT THE TIME
AND I WAS NOT- IF SOMEONE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION BUT I- YOU KNOW
IT MY SENSE WAS THAT THERE'S A
LOT OF CROSS SUBSIDY HAPPENING
AND I'M WONDERING IF THAT'S NOT
SOMETHING WE CAN EMPHASIZE MORE
AND I GUESS THIS CASE LA WAS
POINT ABOUT- ROLLING UP.
FINANCIAL AID INTO HOUSING BUT-
YOU KNOW I KNOW THAT FOR
DIFFERENT FOLKS BASED ON THEIR
INCOME AND NEED GOT DIFFERENT
PACKAGES- SOME FOLKS WERE PAYING
THE FULL. FREIGHT AND THEN
INCLUDED YOU KNOW THAT COSTA
HOUSING AT MARKET RATE IN AND SO
IF THIS WARRANT A MATTER OF LACK
OF HOUSING AND I JUST WONDER IF
WE CAN RELY A LITTLE BIT MORE ON
THAT- PARTICULARLY THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA. AND THIS
GETS KIND OF TO SECOND POINT
WHICH IS- DEPARTMENT FINANCE I
THINK THAT GERMAN LATER DID TRY
TO GET THAT THIS IS BY ASKING
ABOUT YOUR- ASSESSMENT OF THE
DIFFERENT. HOW ABRUPT. PER BY
THE ALEJO. BUT I JUST WANTED TO
ACTUALLY GET. ON ONE BECAUSE I
THINK. FOR ME THIS KIND OF GETS
THE CRUX OF THE ISSUE. YOU RIGHT
NOW AS I UNDERSTAND IT EMPHASIZE
THE ADMINISTRATION EMPHASIZES
THE COST PER BED. AND I THINK
ONE OF THE PURCHASE SUGGESTED BY
THE L. A. O. IS THAT WE COULD
LOOK AT. THE COMPARISON OF THE
COSTS PER BED VIS A VIS THE
MARKET RATE OR OR- NON STUDENT
HOUSING IN TE AREA AND I'M
WONDERING. WHY THAT'S NOT A
PREFERABLE APPROACH BECAUSE THAT
MIGHT GET TO MORE OF. DAY HIGH
COST AREA ISSUE THAT'S BEEN
RAISED THAT IN OTHER WORDS WE'RE
JUST LOOKING AT. A NOMINAL
FIGURE OF COST PER BED- DANNY
NOT. REACHING THE PLACES WHERE
WE REALLY HAVE A CRISIS AND PUT
THE HIGH COST AREAS WHERE WE'RE
FINDING SOMETHING THAT'S BEFORE
WAS MUCH MORE DIFFICULT
CONSTRUCTING SOMETHING.
AFFORDABLE IS MUCH MORE
DIFFICULT SO I WONDER IF YOU ANY
COMMENTS ON THAT- YEAH- SO JUST
TO CLARIFY- WE RANK USING COST
PER BED ND FRIENDS- SO
PROVIDING EITHER IT SUCKS UP
SOME OF THE- APPLICANTS
ACTUALLY- PROPOSED PROVIDING
FRANK LOWER THAN ACTUALLY WHAT
WE HAD. A REQUIRED IN STATUTE-
AND SO THOSE PROJECTS WERE
RANKED HIGHER- IS THERE
PROVIDING THE MOST AFFORDABLE
RENTS FOR STUDENTS- SO IN TERMS
OF- YOU KNOW ORIGINAL METRIC- IT
WAS THAT WAS A- MORE DIFFICULT-
METRIC FOR US TO EVALUATE. AND-
THE LEGISLATURE IS A WELCOME TO
INCLUDE THAT WITHIN THEIR OWN
RECORD OF WITH THEIR OWN SPACE
THAT YOU'RE THEN GOING TO
APPROVED- WE BUT WE WANTED TO BE
MORE. METRIC AND ADDITIONALLY IT
WASN'T SOMETHING THAT WAS
REQUIRED IN STATUTE THAT WE HAD
PUT IN THERE- SO IT WASN'T
SOMETHING THAT- WE HAD
INITIALLY. PROPOSED PUT IN OUR
PROPOSAL IN OUR PROPOSED
RECOMMENDED. AND STRUCTURE. YEAH
I GUESS MY POINT IS THAT IF
YOU'RE TRYING TO ACTUALLY
EMPHASIZE AFFORDABILITY- THAT IS
A REACH AS OPPOSED TO JUST- A.
N. AND WE'RE PRETTY ONLY FOR
PROVIDING SOME CITY IT WAS
PREGNANT. AND I HAVEN'T STUDIED
THIS ISSUE AS CLOSE AS YOU ALL
BUT- IS STRUCK ME THAT THE ON
CAMPUS VERSUS OFF CAMPUS RENT
COMPARISON. MIGHT GET- YOU TO
MORE ACCURATE THAT'S ONE OF
WHICH PARTICULAR CAMPUSES ARE OR
BEDS NEED MORE SUBSIDIES THAN
OTHERS. AND I THINK THAT WAS
MAYBE THAT I DON'T TO PUT WORDS
IN THE ALEJO'S MOUTH BUT THAT
THAT SEEMS TO BE. ONE OF THE
REASONS WE MIGHT CHOOSE THIS
APPROACH AND SO MAYBE THE L. A.
O. COULD COMMENT HERE'S WELL.
RIGHT SO- RIGHT SO IF THEY
MINISTRATION CONSIDER TWO
METRICS AGAIN. A STATE COSTS FOR
AFFORDABLE BAN. SO FOR ALL THE
AFFORDABLE BAGS THAT WERE FILLED
IN A PROJECT THEY DIVIDED THE-
THE- PROPOSED ACOSTA NOT. GOT TO
IT. BECAUSE FOR AFFORDABLE THAT
METRIC. EXCLUDED BANDS THAT
WERE- MORE STANDARD WRENCH SOME
PROJECTS ARE A MIX OF AFFORDABLE
RENT BEDS AND STANDARDBRED BEDS.
ANOTHER IS THAT SECOND METRIC
THAT COMPARED THE PROPOSED RENTS
O THE STATUTORY LIMIT. AND ONE
OPTION WE- RECOMMEND TH
LEGISLATURE CONSIDER. IS TO
COMPARE THE PROPOSED RENTS TO-
COMMUNITY RENTAL RATES AND THROW
OFF CAMPUS HOUSING. RATHER THAN
THE STATUTORY LIMIT. AND THE
PRIMARY VANTAGE WE SEE WITH THAT
IS THAT IT COULD ALLOW FOR A
LITTLE BIT. MORE PRECISE
RANKING- UNDER THE-
ADMINISTRATION'S APPROACH YOU
KNOW BECAUSE AT. LIKE HALF THE
ELIGIBLE PROJECTS. PROPOSED A
MAXIMUM STATUTORY RENTS WE
ALREADY COOLEY. AND SO THIS
WOULD ALLOW FOR A LITTLE MORE
FINE BREAKING. AYE YOU'RE ALSO
CORRECT THAT IN ADDITION TO THAT
IT DOES SORT OF. EMPHASIZE AGAIN
THAT SERVE PORTABILITY AND THAT-
IT. REALLY COMPARES- THE
PROPOSED RENTS TO. A ROUGH
ESTIMATE OF WHAT. THEY'RE SORT
OF ALTERNATIVE IS IN THE
COMMUNITY. THAT COULD BE ANOTHER
GRAND OF CONSIDERING THAT TOO.
AND THEN IT JUST EMPHASIZED
DEPARTMENT FINANCES POINT-
THAT'S- WE- WE RECEIVE SOME
SUPPLEMENTAL INFORMATION FROM UC
AND CSU. ON THOSE ON THOSE RENTS
ARE AFTER THE INITIAL. LETTER
WAS SUBMITTED BY THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. THE INFORMATION IS A
BILL AVAILABLE FOR USING THIS
YEAR'S YOU. THE COLLEGES ARE
MORE A LITTLE BIT. MORE VARIED
AND WHETHER THEY CAN. THEY HAVE
THAT INFORMATION AVAILABLE TO
REPORT. ALSO THE ABILITY OF THE
LEGISLATURE TO TAKE THAT
APPROACH FOR THE COLLEGES MIGHT
BE ONE BUT IF. THANK YOU MISTER
**** CONSTANT TOROS AND I GUESS
I WOULD JUST- ARTICULATE MY OWN
PREFERENCE- AND I DON'T THAT
SHARED BY OTHER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS BUT- IF WE'RE- TO EXTENT
WE'RE PROVIDING ONE TIME FUNDING
FOR HOUSING. I WOULD STRONGLY
PREFER TO SEE THAT- GO ENTIRELY
OR PREDOMINANTLY TOWARDS.
AFFORDABILITY BECAUSE I THINK
THAT IS- THE ROLE AND IF IT MORE
MARKET RATE. HOUSING TO BE BUILT
I FEEL LIKE THAT OUGHT TO BE
THE- WITHIN OTHER FROM FINE
STREAMS THAT NOT FROM THIS ONE
TIME- I LAST. IS I CSU RAISED
POINT THAT- IF IT THE DISH OFTEN
CAME. THROUGH THAT YOU CERTAINLY
HAVE MORE. TO PROPOSE. I SUSPECT
ALSO THE- WITH COMMUNITY. AND
YOU. AND SO I WAS WONDERING IF
YOU COULD COMMENT OR OR
DEPARTMENT FINANCER LA- HAS ANY
IDEA THIS BUT- TO WHAT DEGREE
ARE WE TALKING ABOUT- YOU KNOW
WHAT WHAT IS- IT AS SOON THIS IS
NOT INFINITE BUT WE DO HAVE A
SENSE OF WHAT YOUR- FUNDING.
NEEDS WOULD BE IF WE COULD JUST
YOU KNOW WAVE A MAGIC WAND AND
PROVIDE ALL THE FUNDING WE NEED
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING. YEAH I'M
TRYING TO GET A SENSE OF LIKE
HOW HOW BIG THE PROBLEM IS- EACH
OF THE EACH OF THE DIVISIONS.
AND WHO WOULD YOU LIKE TO START
OH SURE WHILE WHEN WE START THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. GOOD MORNING
AND LISINOPRIL WHICH COMPANY
COLLEGES THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION- ONE I WANT TO
REITERATE- YOUR COMMITMENT TO
AFFORDABILITY WE THINK THAT THE
STATE INVESTMENT REALLY SHOULD.
GO TO SERVE OUR MOST LOW INCOME
STUDENTS NOT REALLY IS AN
OPPORTUNITY THAT IS AHEAD OF US.
I'M FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGES- WE
HAVE- EXTENSIVE PROJECTS. BEFORE
YOU WHEN YOU CONSIDER THESE
YOU'LL HAVE A TOTAL OF NINETY
SEVEN APPLICATIONS. I'M THOSE
ARE TWENTY FIVE ARE FOR
CONSTRUCTION THE REMAINDER ARE-
FOR ELEMENTS OF EITHER
CONSTRUCTION AND- PLANNING. AND
SO ON AS YOU'LL SEE THERE'S
EXTENSIVE NEED- DAY THE PROJECTS
THAT ARE IN EARLY STAGES OF
PLANNING AT SOME POINT. ON WILL
ALSO BE LOOKING FOR RESOURCES
FOR CONSTRUCTION SO WE DO SEE
THAT OVERALL- AND THERE WILL BE
EXTENSIVE NEED. I'M JUST AND-
CONSTRUCTION ALONE BASED ON WHAT
WE- KNOW NOW- DAY COMMUTE
COLLEGE NEED IS ABOUT ONE POINT
SIX. BILLION DOLLARS- WITH
PLANNING WORK TO BEGIN ON ON A
SEVENTY FOUR PROJECTS WHICH
WOULD LATER GIVE US THAT DATA
POINT OF WHAT CONSTRUCTION
WOULDN'T. WOULDN'T S. NECESSITY
SO IT MAY BE JUST. MAYBE TO MAKE
THIS CLEAR TO ME HOW MUCH HAVE
YOU ASKED FOR SO FAR AND AS FAR
AS DOLLARS I THINK WE HAVE A
WHAT A THREE POINT SIX. DOLLAR
FIGURE. AND HOW MUCH MORE WOULD
YOU ASK FOR IF WE HAD MORE
MONEY. THAT'S REALLY WHAT I
WANTED. IN THE END JUST BECAUSE-
OF. OF OUR- MAY BE CONFUSED BY
YOUR THREE POINT SIX BILLION
FIGURE THAT'S ALL THREE BRANCHES
TOGETHER THAT'S NOT JUST
COMMUNITY COLLEGE IN THE
AGGREGATE YOU THE THREE BRANCHES
OF S. OR THREE POINT SIX BILLION
IS MY UNDERSTANDING. AND SO I
DON'T KNOW WHAT YOUR SHARES YOU.
HOW MUCH MORE HOW MUCH OF YOU
ASKED FOR HOW MUCH WOULD YOU ADD
FOR IF WE HAD MORE FUN. SURE
THANK YOU TO ONE CLEAR. THESE
PROJECTS WERE SUBMITTED
INDIVIDUALLY BY THE LOCALLY
GOVERNED DISTRICTS- SO IN TOTAL-
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES NEED IS ONE POINT EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS. AND THAT
INCLUDES BOTH. OF THE- PROJECTS
THAT ARE READY TO MOVE FORWARD
AND CONSTRUCTION AND THOSE THAT
ARE IN THE PLANNING PHASE WHICH
IS ONLY APPLICABLE TO
CALIFORNIA'S ME COLLEGES. THAT
WILL BE READY AT SOME POINT- AND
THAT IS ESTIMATED TO BE A COST-
THAT'S JUST AN ESTIMATE AT THIS
POINT UNTIL THEY COMPLETE THEIR
PLANNING. IF I CAN ASK A QUICK
FOLLOW UP THAT'S A TOTALLY SELF
SELECTED LIST THAT JUST IF THE
INDIVIDUAL COLLEGE. DISTRICTS
CHOSE TO APPLY THERE MAY BE MORE
OUT THERE THEY JUST DIDN'T
CHOOSE TO APPLY RIGHT NOW SO YOU
HAVE A TOTAL OF SORT OF WHO
SELECTED THEMSELVES RIGHT NOW TO
ENTER THE COMPETITION IS THAT
CORRECT. THAT IS CORRECT OKAY
THANK YOU. AND THEN SENATOR MAN
YOU WANT TO GO TO THE NEXT YEAR
OKAY. AND I GUESS THAT THE
UPSHOT IS WE DON'T HAVE A GOOD
SENSE THEN OF WHAT THE DEMAND
MIGHT BE IF WE OPENED UP THE
COPPERSMITH. IF YOU OPEN IT UP
SO WE HAD NEARLY. YES I MEAN
YEAH I JUST WANT YES OR NO
REALLY SORRY. MISTER ROGERS FOR
THE RECORD MISTER MAN JUST
PASSED THE BAR SO HE IS MOVING
TO THE LEGAL SOCRATIC METHOD
THERE. WAS A CREDIT TO BE TO
HAVE YOU ANSWER BUT I JUST I
JUST PURPOSE IS IT YES OR NO I
JUST I REALLY WANT TO KNOW LIKE.
IT'S IT SOUNDS TO ME LIKE WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING IS THERE'S A LOT.
THERE'S A LOT MORE OUT THERE
THAT WE DON'T KNOW ABOUT YOU
DON'T HAVE A GREAT ESTIMATE AT
THIS POINT WHAT THAT MIGHT BE.
THAT IS CORRECT THANK YOU. LET'S
MOVE THIS YEAR'S USE. THANK YOU
MEMBER MEN. IN THE CAMPUS.
CAMPUSES FIVE YEAR PLAN THERE'S
ABOUT A BILLION DOLLARS
REQUESTED FOR STUDENT HOUSING
OVER THE NEXT FIVE YEARS. AND
THE CAMPUSES THAT SUBMITTED- IN
THIS CYCLE THAT WERE NOT
APPROVED. THERE ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED AND THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS THAT WE'RE NOT AND
EITHER IT WE'RE NOT ELIGIBLE
BASED ON TIMING SO. JUST LIKE
OTHERS THEIR CAMPUSES IT DIDN'T
HAVE ADEQUATE TIME TO RESPOND
AND SO I'M- IN IN A ROUGH- OF
BACKING NAPKINS COMPARING
AGAINST OUR FIVE YEAR PLAN I
THINK THE BILLION A BILLION
DOLLARS IT'S KIND OF A ROUND
NUMBER. IF YOU NEED TO
INVESTMENT THERE THANK YOU AND
UC'S. THANK YOU SENATOR MEN ARE
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
SUBMITTED SIX HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS OF PROJECTS FOR THIS
FIRST ROUND. WE HAVE A SET OF
PROJECTS THAT RE NOT WITHIN
THESE AFFORDABILITY METRICS AS
LAID OUT IN THIS GRANT PROGRAM
BUT THAT WOULD UTILIZED LEASE
REVENUE BONDS BASED ON HIGHER
STUDENT RENTS. WE HAVE ABOUT
SIXTEEN SUCH PROJECTS- COMPOSED
OF TOTAL TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
BEDS PLANNED OVER THE NEXT FIVE
YEARS. AND THE TOTAL COST THE
NEW USING THE METRIC OF ABOUT
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
PER BAD- IT'S ABOUT SEVEN AND A
HALF BILLION DOLLARS. THANK YOU
APPRECIATE IT- THAT'S ALL I HAVE. SENATOR- CHAU VOTE. THANK YOU. I'M TRYING NOT TO CHUCKLE
THANKS FOR YOUR COMMENT SENATOR
FLARED- ADJOURNMENT- I DO HAVE A
QUESTION AND I APPRECIATE MY
COLLEAGUES- IN- COMMENTS THAT HE
MADE EARLIER THE QUESTIONS I'M
GOING TO. KIND OF GO ALONG WITH
THAT TRAIN OF THOUGHT WITH
REGARDS TO A POINT THAT WAS MADE
TO ME- THIS PAST WEEKEND AND A
TOUR THAT I MADE- IN WHEN A IN
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. IN THIS
QUESTION ACTUALLY HAS TO DO
WITH- THE RENTS THAT WE EXPECT
OURSTUDENTS TO PAY ARE THEY-
AND I GUESS THIS IS GOING TO BE
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. MY
QUESTION IS DO THEY CONSIDER
THE- WHEN YOU CONSIDER THE RENT
THAT IT THEY'RE EXPECTED TO PAY
FOR THE STUDENTS OR AT THE
HOUSING AVAILABILITY FOR THE
STUDENTS. IN GENERAL DO YOU
FOLKS BASED THAT ON A- ACADEMIC
YEAR FOR A CALENDAR YEAR. SO
CALLOUS A CALENDAR YEAR CALENDAR
YEAR SO THE HOUSING WILL BE
AVAILABLE FOR STUDENTS TWELVE
MONTHS OF THE YEAR AT ALL. THREE
CAMPUSES. YES THAT'S IT WITHIN
STATUTES OKAY PERFECT THANK YOU
SO MUCH IS THAT CURRENTLY THE
PRACTICE OR IS THAT MOVING
FORWARD WELL. TWO BILLION PLUS
ONE. I THOUGHT. DID THAT COME
WHEN I WAS WAITING FOR US AT
YAHOO AS WE'VE HEARD CONCERNS-
SENATOR DISTANCED SAY EVER
TENANTS FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA OUR STUDENT HOUSING
RENTAL RATES ARE BASED ON A NINE
MONTH ACADEMIC CALENDAR AND
STUDENTS CAN RENT. A DORMITORY
ROOM FOR AN EXTRA COST DURING
THE SUMMER. BUT THEY DO HAVE THE
ABILITY TO HAVE A CONTRACT FOR
TWELVE MONTHS. YES MOST OF OUR
CAMPUSES OFFER GOT IT SOME
DORMITORY BASIS YES. THE MOST
BUT NOT ALL THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT ARE I WOULD LIKE TO
CONSIDER- AND HAVE US MOVING
FORWARD JUST BECAUSE- IT WAS
BROUGHT TO MY ATTENTION THAT
MANY OF OUR STUDENTS. MAY NOT
HAVE THE ABILITY TO GO HOME-
DURING THE SUMMER OR DURING
BREAKS AND SO- YOU KNOW I WAS
THINKING BACK OF MY YOU KNOW MY
TIME IN SCHOOL AND- I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GO HOME BUT THERE
WAS A TIME WHERE I THOUGHT I'M
LIKE WELL WHERE DO I GO NOW- SO
I UST. IF WE'RE GOING TO BE
REALLY GIVING THEM PEACE OF MIND
I REALLY WOULD LIKE TO CONSIDER
AND I'M NOT SURE OF MY
COLLEAGUES FEEL ABOUT THAT BUT
THEY WE CONSIDER HOUSING FOR
STUDENTS THAT WE DO CONSIDER A
TWELVE MONTH CONTRACT OR THE
AVAILABILITY TO HAVE THAT
ACCESSIBLE FOR THEM FOR TWELVE
MONTHS VERSUS JUST THE ACADEMIC
YEAR- JUST. SOMETHING TO. PONDER
UPON. I'M JUST PLANTING THE
SEEDS ON THAT END. DO WE HAVE A
QUESTION ON THE APPLICATION FOR
HOUSING BY THE WAY. YOU MEAN
WHETHER OR NOT THEY WANT TWELVE
YEAR YEAH. MONTHS HOUSE IF
THEY'VE THERE'S A NEED WHO WOULD
YOU LIKE TO TAKE A SHOT AT THAT
QUESTION. I GUESS IT WOULD HAVE
TO BE THE CC THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES THIS YEAR'S USUALLY
UC'S LET'S JUST PICK ONE ARE YOU
SEE DO YOU HAVE THAT ON YOUR
QUOTE- YOUR QUESTION WHETHER OR
NOT THEY WANT. TWELVE MONTHS.
I'M SO SIR I'LL HAVE TO GET BACK
TO YOU ON WHETHER OR NOT WE ASK
THE STUDENTS THAT QUESTION MA'AM
LET ME TRY THE CSU FOR SENATOR
TROUBLED DO YOU KNOW THE ANSWER
TO THAT QUESTION. I DO NOT BUT-
WE WERE PLANNING TO ACCOMMODATE
THE HOUSING DURING THE SUMMER.
WE JUST MAY HAVE TO MOVE THEM
TO. A CERTAIN DORM SO WE DON'T
HAVE KIDS OUT SPREAD OUT ACROSS
DIFFERENT. HOUSING TYPES OF WHEN
THERE'S FEWER STUDENTS THERE
DURING THE SUMMER THAT'S THE
OTHER PART OF THE DISCUSSION YOU
HAD WITH HOUSING DIRECTORS.
THANK YOU. HI I APPRECIATE THE
TERM KIDS THE- I THOUGHT I WAS
AN ADULT WHEN I WAS A STUDENT.
AND COMMUNITY. YOU HAVE ONE
MORE. YOU HAVE TO CROSS A TWELVE
CAMPUSES ABOUT HALF OF THEM
OFFER HOUSE SCENE IN THE SUMMER
ON THE OTHERS DO NOT. OKAY
REISER HAVE WE ARE GO HEAD I
JUST I HOPE THAT WE CAN
RECONSIDER- THE HOUSING
AVAILABILITY- TO OUR STUDENTS ON
A- BASED ON A CALENDAR YEAR
VERSUS AN ACADEMIC YEAR JUST AS
AN OPTION FOR THOSE THAT MAY
NEED IT. FOR ME THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ARM. THAT WAS A REALLY
DETAILED CONVERSATION I'M REALLY
GRATEFUL FOR TO PUT IF WE SPENT
AN HOUR ON EVERYONE OF THE
REMAINING ITEMS WE WILL BE HERE
TILL TEN O'CLOCK TONIGHT BUT I
THINK THE FIRST TWO ITEMS WERE
THE ONES THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE
THAT. THE THE- BIGGEST ONES TO
CONSIDER AND I WANT TO SAY THAT
THERE WAS A LOT OF FOOD FOR
THOUGHT IN THIS AND A GOOD
CONVERSATION AND WE WANT TO TAKE
IT INTO ACCOUNT AND WHAT THE
FINAL BUDGET ACTIONS ARE NOT I
HAVE TO MAKE A SLIGHTLY SNARKY
COMMENT TO THE CSU SYSTEM WHICH
IS THAT. HE IN THE SENATE'S
PROPOSAL WE ADDED ONE POINT NINE
BILLION DOLLARS FOR THE CSU. A
BILLION FOR DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
AND FOUR HUNDRED FOR OPERATING
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION FOR HOUSING
AND- AND THE RESPONSE WAS TO ASK
FOR FIFTY MILLION MORE SO YOU
MIGHT WANT TO PRIORITIZE WITHIN
THE ADDITIONAL MONEY WHAT YOU
THINK IS MOST IMPORTANT IF. IF
YOU REALLY STRONGLY BELIEVE THAT
FIFTY MILLION IT'S IMPORTANT TO
DO THAN WITHIN WHAT YOU'RE
GETTING YOU MIGHT DECIDE TO
PRIORITIZE IT OVER. SOMETHING
ELSE THAT MIGHT BE AN
EXPENDITURE OR ME THANK
EVERYONE. OF FOR THAT
CONVERSATION AND WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE TO ISSUE TWENTY THREE.
WHICH IS THE HIGHER EDUCATION
COMPACTS WITH UC AND CSU AND THE
ROAD MAP WITH THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM. WE HAVE FIVE
DIFFERENT PRESENTERS REBEKAH
KIRK FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE JENNIFER PURCELL FROM
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. AGAIN SAY JEFF FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AGAIN
LISETTE FROM THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE AND
RYAN STORM FROM THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY SYSTEM. WILL
TAKE HIM IN THAT ORDER AND I
THINK GOING FORWARD. THIS IS NOT
A TIME FOR A FIVE MINUTE
PRESENTATIONS SO A BECAUSE WE
REALLY HAVE TO STEP THROUGH THE
REST OF THE AGENDA SO. I WILL-
RECOGNIZE PEOPLE IN THE ORDER
THAT I JUST IDENTIFIED FOR.
ISSUE TWENTY THREE START WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE. THE
MORNING RECORD DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. IN CONJUNCTION WITH THE
RELEASE OF THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
IN JANUARY THE ADMINISTRATION
ANNOUNCED COMPACTS WITH THE UC
NCS YEAR AND THE ROAD MAP WITH
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM.
THESE FIVE YEAR AGREEMENTS
REPRESENT DISCRETE SET OF SHARED
PRIORITIES. BETWEEN THE
ADMINISTRATION EACH SEGMENT. BUT
THEY ALSO EMPHASIZED THE
IMPORTANCE OF INTERSECTING
COOPERATION. THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET SUMMARY OUTLINED MANY OF
THE SPECIFIC GOALS AND
COMMITMENTS FOR EACH SEGMENT
WHICH BUILD UPON EACH SYSTEMS
EXISTING CALLS. BEING UC TWENTY
THIRTY THE CSU GRADUATION
INITIATIVE. TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
AND THE CCC VISION FOR SUCCESS.
BROADLY SPEAKING THE GOALS AND
COMMITMENTS IN THE AGREEMENT
ENHANCE ACCESS TO THE
UNIVERSITY'S INCREASE
AFFORDABILITY IMPROVE EQUITY
INCREASE OUR SIGNAL COOPERATION
TO BENEFIT STUDENTS. STRENGTHEN
CAREER PIPELINES FOR HIGH NEED
FIELDS AND PROMOTE ACCESS TO
ONLINE SECURE ONLINE LEARNING
FOR STUDENTS WHO ARE INTERESTED
IN THOSE OPPORTUNITIES.
ADDITIONAL DETAIL WILL BE
PROVIDED WITH THE RELEASE OF THE
MAYOR VISION I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
APPRECIATE THOSE COMMENTS WILL
MOVE TO THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. SO JENNIFER
PATELLA FROM THE L. A. ELLIS WE
HAVE SEVERAL OVER ARCHING
CONCERNS WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
COMPACT AND ROADMAPS. SO THERE'S
FIFTY FIVE IN TOTAL EXPECTATIONS
ACROSS THE THREE SEGMENTS YOU
CAN SEE THOSE ON AGES TWENTY ONE
AND TWENTY TWO OF YOUR AGENDA.
THERE ARE INCONSISTENCIES IN THE
PERFORMANCE EXPECTATIONS SO IF
YOU LOOK FOR EXAMPLE IN THE
AFFORDABILITY CATEGORY ONLY YOU
SEE IS EXPECTED TO OFFER A TAX
FREE PATHWAY FOR UNDERGRADUATES.
ONLY UC AND CSU ARE EXPECTED TO
REDUCE THE COST OF TEXTBOOKS AND
INSTRUCTIONAL MATERIALS. NONE OF
THE EXPECTATIONS NONE OF THOSE
FIFTY FIVE EXPECTATIONS COME
WITH A COST ESTIMATE. FOR THE
SEGMENT'S MAINTAINABLE TO ABSORB
THE COST OF SOME OF THE
EXPECTATIONS WITHIN THE PROPOSED
SPACE INCREASES BUT LIKELY
OTHERS WOULD REQUIRE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES FOR EXAMPLE ENROLLMENT
GROWTH THE TRADITIONAL STATE OF
PRACTICES TO PROVIDE THAT ABOVE
THE BASE INCREASE. THE STATE
ALSO NORMALLY FUNDS FINANCIALLY
IT OBJECTIVES VERY UNLIKELY YOU
SEE COULD PROVIDE DEBT FREE
EDUCATION FOR EVERY
UNDERGRADUATE WITHIN ITS
EXISTING RESOURCES. EXPANDING
PROGRAMS AND HEALTH CARE AND
CLIMATE ACTION FIELDS WOULD VERY
LIKELY TAKE ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
SO THE PLANS DON'T SEEM TO BE
HOLDING TOGETHER FROM A FISCAL
PERSPECTIVE. THANK UNDER ALSO
SET FORTH. FOR WHAT WOULD HAPPEN
IF THE SEGMENTS MASS ONE OR MORE
OF THE EXPECTATIONS. SEPARATELY
THE LEGISLATURE TRIES TO ENSURE
THAT THE REPERCUSSIONS ARE
APPROPRIATE O JUST A COUPLE OF
THE FIFTY FIVE EXPECTATIONS
AREN'T MEL MATT THE SEGMENTS ONE
INPUT ALL OF THEIR BASED
INCREASE- ACT WOULDN'T IT
WOULDN'T BE AT ISSUE. IT'S NOT
EVEN CLEAR THAT FOR GOING A
FUNDING INCREASE WOULD BE AN
APPROPRIATE REPERCUSSION THAT
MIGHT BE MORE APPROPRIATE TO
REVISIT THAT POLICY INTERVENTION
THE PROGRAM DESIGN REALLOCATE
EXISTING RESOURCE SAYS. IN SOME
INSTANCES A SEGMENT MIGHT EVEN
NEED MORE RESOURCES TO MEET
PERFORMANCE EXPECTATIONS.
THINKING THROUGH THE APPROPRIATE
REPERCUSSIONS FOR MISSING ANY
PARTICULAR EXPECTATION THAT'S
GOING TO TAKE SOME TIME CAREFUL
DELIBERATION. WHAT ARE YOUR BUT
PLANS LIKE COMPAQ AND ROAD MAPS
THEY ALSO TEND TO GET OFF TRACK
THERE HASN'T BEEN A CONTACT IN
THE PAST THAT HAS BEEN ABLE TO
BE ADHERED TO THROUGHOUT THE
PERIOD AS PROPOSED. SOMETIMES
FISCAL CONDITIONS IMPROVE
SOMETIMES THEY WERE SON. LASTLY
OUR MOST FUNDAMENTAL CONCERN IS
THAT WHEN GOVERNOR'S AND GO
DIRECTLY TO THE STATEMENTS AND
ESTABLISH PERFORMANCE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND BUDGET PLANS
THEY SIDESTEPPED THE
LEGISLATURE. THOUGH AS PART OF
THE ANNUAL BUDGET PROCESS ONE OF
THE MAIN OBJECTIVES FOR THE
LEGISLATURE IS TO WORK WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION WORK WITH THE
SEGMENTS. THAT DECIDE HOW
THEY'RE FINDING MODELS AND
PERFORMANCE EXPECTATIONS SHOULD
BE ADJUSTED. SO WE JUST
ENCOURAGE YOU TO UNDERTAKE THIS
PROCESS OVER THE REMAINDER OF
THE BUDGET CYCLE AND WHATEVER
YOU SETTLE UPON AS YOUR FUNDING
AND PERFORMANCE ADJUSTMENTS. YOU
WOULD GO AHEAD AND PUT THOSE IN
BUDGET ACTON TRAILER LEGISLATION
FOR THE SAKE OF TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. THANK THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WILL MOVE TO THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU SAY OVER TEN AND FOR THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA I WANT
TO THANK GOVERNOR NEWSOM FOR HIS
PLAN TO STRENGTHEN THE
UNIVERSITY AND BETTER SERVE
STUDENTS THROUGH A FIVE YEAR
FUNDING COMPACT THAT OFFERS
RELIABLE FINANCIAL SUPPORT. FOR
OUR CAMPUSES AND DEAR AND THE
ARTICULATION OF SHARED GOALS THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED COMPACT
FOCUSES TO UNIVERSITIES FUTURE
WORK ON ACCESS. ACCESS
AFFORDABILITY IN AND
INTERSEGMENT FULL COLLABORATION.
THE UNIVERSITY IS REQUESTING
THAT THE GOALS OUTLINED IN THE
MULTI YEAR COMPACT REMAIN
ASPIRATIONAL RATHER THAN
INSTITUTE PUNISHMENTS FOR DO
UNIVERSITIES FAILURE TO MEET
SPECIFIC METRIC. TO ENSURE THAT
THE LEGISLATURE FEELS
COMFORTABLE WITH THE
UNIVERSITIES PROGRESS TOWARDS
THE SHARED GOALS WE COULD
PROVIDE REGULAR REPORTING OR
BRIEFINGS TO LEGISLATORS AND
THEIR STAFF. UNIVERSITY SEES THE
COMPACT GOALS AS A CONVERSATION
ON REACHING SUCCESS TOGETHER
WITH THE GOVERNOR AND THE
LEGISLATURE. IN TERMS OF
ENROLLMENT GROWTH UNIVERSITY
WOULD MEASURE UNDERGRADUATE
ENROLLMENT GROWTH AS GROWTH IN
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS IN ADDITION
WE WOULD UTILIZE THE FULL TIME
EQUIVALENT STUDENT METRIC RATHER
THAN STUDENT HEAD COUNT. USING
THESE CRITERIA A 1%
UNDERGRADUATE STUDENT GROWTH
WOULD BE JUST OVER TWO THOUSAND
STUDENTS ANNUALLY. IF THE
LEGISLATURE WERE INTERESTED IN
INCREASING UC UNDERGRADUATE
ENROLLMENT BEYOND THE AMOUNT
INCLUDED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET FOR TWENTY TO TWENTY
THREE AND INCLUDED IN THE
COMPACT WE DO REQUEST THAT EACH
STUDENT BE PROVIDED THE FULL
STATE SHERIFF THE MARGINAL COST
OF INSTRUCTION FUNDING.
RECEIVING FULL FUNDING FOR EACH
STUDENT IT'S IMPORTANT TO
CAMPUSES ABILITY TO HIRE FACULTY
OFFER ENOUGH COURSES AND PROVIDE
STUDENTS SERVICES NECESSARY FOR
SUCCESS I LOOK FORWARD TO OUR
ONGOING CONVERSATION. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME TODAY. THANK YOU
MOVE ON THE CA COLLEGE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. GOOD
MORNING AGAIN. SENATOR LAYER TO
MEMBERS OF THE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE LESTAT NUMBER
EXECUTIVE VICE YOU THROUGH THE
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
ROADMAP FOR CALIFORNIA COLLEGES
SETS A BOLD VISION FOR HIGHER
EDUCATION AS A LEVER FOR
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY AND MEANS
TO CLOSE EQUITY GAPS. THIS
FRAMEWORK BUILDS UPON THE BOARD
OF GOVERNORS VISION FOR SUCCESS
GOALS I WOULD CREATE NEW AVENUES
FOR DATA SHARING CROSS SYSTEM
COLLABORATION AND FUNDS RESOURCE
IS- FOR BOTH COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AND THAT HAVE CLEAR EMPHASIS ON-
I AM ADVANCING STUDENT SUCCESS
AND CLOSING RACIAL EQUITY GAPS.
THE ROADMAP COMPLEMENTING
EXISTING GOALS WITHIN THE VISION
FOR SUCCESS AND VALIDATES THE
WORK THAT HAS BEEN PRIORITIZE
OVER THE FIVE LAST FIVE YEARS
BUT JOINS US IN THE HARD WORK
THAT STILL CONTINUES AS WE
RECOVER FROM THE PANDEMIC. SINCE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE- COMPANY
CAN COLLEGES HAVE DILIGENTLY
WORKED TOWARD TO THE VISION FOR
SUCCESS- LOCAL DISTRICTS ALSO
ADOPTED VISION GOALS AND ALIGN
WITH WITH AB EIGHTEEN OWN NINE
I'M TO PUT STUDENTS FIRST AND
HOLD SYSTEMS ACCOUNTABLE TO
INFRASTRUCTURES AND ENSURE THAT
STUDENTS FROM ALL BACKGROUNDS
AND THEIR FAMILIES CAN SIXTY. SO
WE SEE GREAT ALIGNMENT ONE AND
THE VISION FOR SUCCESS IN SOME
OF THE CLEAR GOALS AND GETS
DECENT FOOD ON GOALS AROUND
COMPLETION TRANSFER EFFICIENCY
EMPLOYMENT- AND AS I MENTIONED
ON SUCCESS IN EQUITY CLOSING
EQUITY GAPS ACROSS ALL REGIONS
AND ACROSS ALL STUDENT GROUPS.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO THE ROAD
ADDING MOMENTUM TO THE WORK AND
JOINING US IN PARTNERSHIP IN
THESE LONG HELD GOALS SO THEY
COMMUNITY COLLEGES DON'T HAVE TO
GO EDITABLE ALONE WE HAVE STATE
LEADERSHIP ON ON OUR SIDE THANK. YOU VERY MUCH HAPPY ANSWER
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
LET'S MOVE ON THE COUNTY STATE
IN SYSTEM. THANK YOU SEVEN LAYER
- MY NAME IS RUNNING STORM I AM
THE ASSISTANT VICE CHANCELLOR
FOR BUDGET FOR THE OFFICE OF THE
CHANCELLOR- IN TERMS OF OUR
COMMENTS ON THE CONTACT YOU KNOW
IT'S AN IMPORTANT MILESTONE FOR
THIS ISSUE. ESPECIALLY FOR
FINANCIAL SUSTAINABILITY
PREDICTABILITY- IT'S NOT GOING
TO FIND ALL OF UNIVERSITIES
NEEDS AND REVIEW THIS BUDGET
COMPACT IS A CRITICAL SAFETY NET
TO PROTECT UNIVERSITY FROM.
THOSE ECONOMIC FLUCTUATIONS OVER
THE NEXT FIVE YEARS THAT ARE
LIKELY TO ARRIVE. THAT IS
BECAUSE THERE ARE NO LAWS AND
THERE ARE NO CONSTITUTIONAL
PROVISIONS THAT PROVIDE ANY
BUDGETARY ASSURANCES OR
PREDICTABILITY FROM YOUR YEAR.
SO WE THEREFORE ARE GRATEFUL TO
GOVERNOR NEWSOM AND HIS
ADMINISTRATION FOR A MULTI YEAR
COMMITMENT. I ALSO JUST FOR
BREVITY'S SAKE WILL ONLINE A LOT
OF WE AGREE- A LOT WITH WHAT
THAT REPRESENTED FROM UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA STATED ABOUT TRUMP
ROMANCE. TERMS OF ACCOUNTABILITY
PAYING VISITS TO OUR SENATORS
AND SEVEN MEMBERS TO GIVE
UPDATES. ON- ON THE OUTCOMES OF
THE GOALS WERE VERY OPEN TO
THOSE SORTS OF CONVERSATIONS SO
. MY WORRY I WOULD SAY- COMMENTS
MADE BY MY COLLEAGUE SAY
PRETENDING AND I ARE ARE LINE
PRETTY WELL IN THE CONTACT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH LET ME
BEGIN WITH A QUESTION FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND THAT
IS. THE GOVERNOR PRESENTED HIS
BUDGET WITH THE IDEAS FOR THE
CONTACTS ON JANUARY TENTH AND WE
HEARD IT IN FEBRUARY AND SAID.
THAT IT WAS NOT A DONE DEAL FOR
US TO WE COULD ACTUALLY SEE THE
COMPACT AND KNOW WHAT'S IN IT WE
HAVE THE- THE GLOBAL THINGS BUT
WE'RE STILL HAVING A
PRESENTATIONS. FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA ABOUT
WHAT ENFORCEMENT MIGHT BE AN
ENFORCEMENT IS NOT CLEAR BECAUSE
WE HAVE NOT SEEN A CONTACT. WHEN
MIGHT WE ACTUALLY SEE A COMPACT
THAT IS BEING REFERRED TO HERE.
THANK YOU SENATOR WE DO
ANTICIPATE PROVIDING ADDITIONAL
DETAIL AND THE ACTUAL CONTACT
AND ROADMAP DOCUMENTS ALONG WITH
THE MAY REVISION RELIEF. OKAY
THANK YOU SB BECAUSE I THINK
THAT THERE'S AN ADDITIONAL
QUESTION RAISED WHICH IS WE WANT
TO GO PAST THE GOVERNOR
ORIGINALLY SAID. DO I THINK FIVE
POINT THREE OR OR SOME 5%
INCREASE IN FUNDING FOR THE
THREE BRANCHES IN EXCHANGE FOR
THE COMPACTS AND WE WANT TO GO
FURTHER AND WE ALSO WANT TO
KNOW. WHETHER WE TRIP OVER THE
CONTACT CONTACTED TRYING TO HELP
THE DIFFERENT BRANCHES FURTHER
IN WHAT WE DO IN THE BUDGET SO
THOSE WILL BE VERY IMPORTANT
QUESTIONS AND WE JUST AS THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIANS YES
YOU ARE VERY CURIOUS ABOUT. WHAT
THE ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM MIGHT
BE AND I A LISTENING TO
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA SAYING WE
THINK IT'S A CONVERSATION MY
GUESS IS IT'S A LITTLE MORE
SPECIFIC THAN JUST A
CONVERSATION IT'S REALLY WORKING
AT IF YOU GET ADDITIONAL FUNDS
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO AND SOME
OF THE METRICS ACTUALLY HAVE TO
BE MEASURED AND TIED TOGETHER
BUT- IT SEEMS LIKE. FOUR MONTHS
AFTER IT WAS PROPOSED THIS IS
STILL AN OPEN QUESTION ABOUT
WHAT IT IS SO WE WANT TO KNOW
SPECIFICALLY TO BE ABLE TO MAKE
AN APPROPRIATE JUDGMENT IN THE
BUDGET. AND THEN BEFORE MOVING
TO MY COLLEAGUES LET ME JUST ASK
ONE OTHER QUESTION OF THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM AND
THAT IS THAT- AT THE TIME WE
HEARD THE BUDGET- IN FEBRUARY.
THE NOT EVERY CAMPUS HAD
REPORTED ON ENROLLMENT WHAT IS
THE ACTUAL STATUS OF ENROLLMENT
TRENDS IN THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM WHAT WHAT DID THOSE
REPORTS INDICATE TO YOU.
INTERLAYER TO CALIFORNIA'S ME
COLLEGES THAT HAVE SEEN- AS
EXPECTED IMPACTS FROM THE
PANDEMIC- YEAR TO YEAR
ENROLLMENT IS DOWN NEARLY. SINCE
THE START OF THE PANDEMIC'S
ACTUALLY OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS
ROMANS ARE DOWN NEARLY FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND STUDENTS AND
WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR SOME OF THE
INVESTMENTS IN STUDENT RANGE AND
JUST EXCUSE ME FOR INTERRUPTING
BUT JUST FOR PEOPLE THAT. DON'T
MEMORIZED THE TOTAL STUDENT
ENROLLMENT- WHAT IS THE PERCENT
OR RELATIVE MEASURE OF FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND STUDENTS BEING
DOWN. IT ROUGHLY- CAN'T ARM AT
THE START OF THE PANDEMIC THE
CALIFORNIA ECOLOGISTS ARE ONE
POINT ONE. MILLION STUDENTS SO
WE'RE NOW CLOSER TO ONE POINT
EIGHT I'M SO ROUGHLY. I THINK.
FROM YOU SOMETHING WASN'T RIGHT
KNOW WHAT YOU JUST SAID BECAUSE
YOU WENT FROM ONE POINT ONE
MILLION TO ONE POINT EIGHT
MILLION THAT'S NOT A LOSS OF
FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND STUDENTS.
WE'RE WE'RE CLOSER TO- IN OUR
TOTAL ENROLLMENT WE WERE CLOSER
TO WAR ONE ONE POINT TWO R. AT
THE START- ESTIMATE DOWN TO ONE
POINT ONE BUT WE'RE ROUGHLY DOWN
ABOUT 14% FROM THE TWENTY
NINETEEN PLAN I'M CONFUSED
BECAUSE YOU SAID YOU WERE DOWN
FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND BORDERS TO
FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND FIT IN
THAT BECAUSE YOU WENT FROM ONE
POINT TWO MILLION TO ONE POINT
ONE MILLION. WHAT WERE IN MY
RUDIMENTARY CASE THROUGH TWELFTH
MATH THAT IS NOT FOUR HUNDRED
POUNDS. ARE THERE TO FIGHT TO
PROVIDE ASSISTANCE ON THIS I
THINK- SHE'S TALKING ABOUT- FPS
FULL TIME EQUIVALENT STUDENT- IN
ENROLLMENT BASIS- THE SYSTEM
WENT FROM. YOU JUST TAP IT YOU
JUST HAPPEN TO BE CHRISTOPHER
FERGUSON FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE RIGHT AND APOLOGIES YOUR
CORRECT GOOD I JUST WANT TO GAS
STATIONS FOR THE LISTENING
AUDIENCE SO- KEEP GOING STARTED
RIGHT. NO NO OKAY APPRECIATE
THE- THE NOTE I DID FORGET TO
MENTION MY NAME SO ON A ROLLING
BASIS THE SYSTEM WAS AROUND TWO
POINT ONE TO TWO POINT TWO
MILLION STUDENTS. NOW ON A
ROLLING BASIS IT'S AROUND.
BERKELEY. ONE POINT SEVEN
MILLION TOTAL STREAMS. AND SO
THAT X. THE- FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND. THANK YOU CORRECT
ANYBODY ANYTHING YOU WANT TO.
ADD TO THAT ANSWER- FROM THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM BEFORE
WE MOVE ON. NO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- FOR LOOKING INTO THAT AND
THAT CLARITY GREAT THANK YOU
LET'S GO TO MY COLLEAGUES ANY
QUESTIONS. CENTAMIN HAS A
COMMENT- SO I SHARE THE BROAD
POLICY GOALS EXPRESSED IN THE
CONTACTS WE WANT GREATER
AFFORDABILITY OBVIOUSLY WHAT WE
WANT- IDEALLY TO MOVE TO DEBT
FREE COLLEGE WE WANT BETTER
OUTCOMES- I DO SHARE THE ALEJO'S
CONCERNS THOUGH AND I THINK THEY
RAISED A NUMBER OF THEM I
INCLUDING INCONSISTENCIES IN
SOME OF THE POLICY GOALS. ARE
MISSING COST DATA- AND MAYBE
MORE DETAILS AS FAR AS HOW WE'RE
GONNA LINK EXPECTATIONS
APPROPRIATE. OUTCOMES- YOU KNOW
I THINK THE OTHER THING YOU KNOW
IT'S I'M I'M NEW TO THE
LEGISLATURE IN MY SECOND YEAR
BUT- I DO REMEMBER SCHOOLHOUSE
ROCK AND YOU KNOW THERE ARE
THREE BRANCHES OF GOVERNMENT AND
I REALLY WOULD ENCOURAGE THE
DEPARTMENT FINEST AND THE
GOVERNOR'S ADMINISTRATION. TO
NOT JUST HAND US THIS BY FIAT
BUT TO WORK WITH US- IT IS GIVEN
THAT WE'RE THE ONES ARE EXPECTED
TO VOTE ON THIS- TO VOTE AND
FILL IN THE DETAILS I THINK IT
BE HELPFUL. TO HAVE A MORE
COLLABORATIVE APPROACH BUT- I
JUST WANT TO STATE FOR THE
RECORD THAT I SHARE THE CONCERNS
RAISED BY THE L. L. THE- THANK
YOU AND IT'S ALWAYS DANGEROUS
WHEN YOU HAVE. MUSIC ANALOGIES A
IT'S A CHALLENGE TO THE REST OF
US AND I REMEMBER WHEN I WAS IN
THE ASSEMBLY AND WAS BUDGET
CHAIR SINGING YOU CAN ALWAYS GET
WHICH WANT TO. SOMEBODY AT THE
TIME A CENTER ROAD SHOW BOB DO
YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS. ALL
COMMENTS M. SO I DO JUST HAVE
ONE QUESTION AND THAT'S- FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ADD TO
ADDRESS THE OBSERVATIONS MADE BY
THE L. A. RELATED TO THE
INCONSISTENCIES AND EXPECTATIONS
ACROSS THE SEGMENT. WE CAN SPEAK
TO THAT- AS MENTIONED THE
COMPACT AND ROADMAP GOALS
LARGELY BUILD UPON EACH
SEGMENT'S EXISTING PLANS AND
GOALS FOR YOU SEE THE UC TWENTY
THIRTY PLAN. THE CSU GRADUATION
MISSION OF TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
AND THEN THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
VISION FOR SIX FIVE. WE HAVE
ENGAGED IN THE PROCESS. WANTING
TO REALLY ACKNOWLEDGE THE WORK
THAT'S ALREADY BEING DONE BY
EACH SEGMENT AND TO FURTHER THAT
WORK WITHIN THE FIVE YEAR TERM
OF THE CONTRACT. LOOKING AT
REALLY THE FOCUS ON SHARED
PRIORITIES AND GOALS. WE DO
HOWEVER ACKNOWLEDGE THAT WORK
HAS BEEN APPROACHED SOMEWHAT
DIFFERENTLY BY EACH SEGMENT AND
SO SOME OF THE INCONSISTENCIES
WITH THE L. L. HAS SPOKEN TO.
REALLY AROSE JUST BY NATURE OF
AREAS THAT HAVE BEEN EMPHASIZED
AS WELL AS COMMITMENTS AND GOALS
THAT EACH SEGMENT WERE ABLE TO
ADVANCE WITHIN THE TERM OF THE
COMPACT AND WITHIN THE
RESOURCES. PROVIDED FOR SIMILAR
PROPOSED. FOR SEVENTEEN AS
COMPACT AGREEMENTS. PERFECT
THANK YOU. OKAY YOU VERY MUCH
THEN THAT- COMPLETE. THAT ISSUE
AND LET ME THANK EVERYONE FOR-
THEIR COMMENTS AND WE WILL LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING WHAT'S IN THE
ME MAY REVISE WHICH IT SOUNDS
LIKE WILL A PERCENT ADDITIONAL
DETAIL ON WILL GO ACCORDINGLY
BASED ON OUR COMMENTS QUESTIONS
THIS YEAR. AND WILL MOVE ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY FOUR WHICH
IS. THE SENATE PROPOSALS FOR
FINANCIAL AID REFORM WE HAVE ONE
LISTED- WITNESS LISA KING FROM
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
BUT WE HAVE OTHER PEOPLE. ON
STANDBY FOR QUESTIONS FROM- THE
STUDENT AID COMMISSION OF THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE AND I BELIEVE SOMEBODY
FROM FINANCE SO WE'LL GO TO LISA
CAME FROM THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. GOOD MORNING
CHEN MEMBERS RETHINKING WHAT THE
L. A. M. AYE FINANCE AYE STOCK
INTRODUCED THE FINANCIALLY
PROPOSALS INCLUDED IN THE SENATE
DEMOCRATS BUDGET PLAN PUTTING
LOVE TO WORK. THE PROPOSAL
LISTED IN YOUR GENDER BEGINNING
AT THE BOTTOM OF PAGE TWENTY
NINE. THE FIRST FOUR HOLES WOULD
PROVIDE A TOTAL OF A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY SIX MILLION ONGOING IN
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE.
EXPANDING CAL GRANT PROGRAMS.
IT'LL OF THE FUNDS WILL GO
TOWARD PROVIDING ADDITIONAL
LIVING COSTS IFTEEN FOR HELPING
THIS AT THE END. BY INCREASING
THE HOW CAN BE ACCESS TO WORK BY
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS. I'M MAKING
A PROPORTIONAL INCREASED
ACCOUNTANCY BOOK IN THE FLY
AWARD. THE REMAINING THREE
HEALTHCARE PROPOSAL THE SENIOR
GENDER RELATED TO EXPANDING WHAT
AMOUNTS IN ELIGIBILITY. FOR
HEALTHCARE RECIPIENTS ATTENDING
THE INDEPENDENT COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES. HOW CAN FASHION.
INCLUDES OPENED FOR TO FINANCE
AID PROGRAMS PHYSICALLY IT
INCLUDES TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION ON GOING PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND FOR
THE STUDENT SUCCESS COMPLETION
GRANTS THE FUNDS WOULD DOUBLE
WATER NOW WHAT SHOULD GO TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS
RECEIVING CAL GRANT SQUIRRELS
FULL TIME. FINALLY THE PLAN
INCLUDES TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY
SEVEN MILLION ONGOING GENERAL
FUND IN TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY
THREE ON TOP OF THE AMOUNT
PROVIDED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. FOR THE MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM. AS WELL AS
ADDITIONAL ON GOING ON VACATION
IN THE OUTER SUCH THAT THIS NEW
PROGRAM WOULD BE FULLY FUNDED.
BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE TWENTY
SIX. APPLE IMPLEMENTATION THIS
PROGRAM WOULD BE INTENDED TO
COVER THE TOTAL COST OF
ATTENDANCE FOR UC AND CSU
STUDENT. AFTER ACCOUNTING FOR
THE AVAILABLE RESOURCES. THANK
YOU I'D BE HAPPY TAKING
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
M. I'M GLAD THIS IS JUST BEING
AIRED AND DISCUSSED BECAUSE IT'S
SOMETHING THE SENATE WANTS TO
DO. I WANT TO ASK ONE QUESTION
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
I DON'T KNOW WHO'S ON STAND BY.
AND THAT IS OUR REPORT INDICATES
THAT. OF LAST YEAR'S ASSEMBLY
BILL FOURTEEN FIFTY SIX WITH THE
GOVERNOR VETOED AND WOULD'VE
DONE. A MORE ON STUDENT AID- IT
NOW WE'RE COMING BACK THAT
BILL'S BEEN REINTRODUCED IN SOME
FORM AND- IT REALLY SPECIFY SOME
OF THE ADDITIONS THAT DIFFERENT
PEOPLE IN THE LEGISLATURE WANNA
MAKE TO THIS PROGRAM. OR THEIR
CONVERSATIONS GOING ON ABOUT
THIS BECAUSE I THINK IF THERE'S
SOMETHING THAT COMES FROM THAT
PROCESS OR THAT BILL IT'S GOING
TO INFORM THE BUDGET DECISIONS
AND I WONDERED IF ANYTHING IS.
IF THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE CAN
COMMENT ON WHETHER THERE ARE ANY
CONVERSATIONS GOING ON ON
RESOLVING THOSE CONFLICTS THAT
CAME OUT OF THE VETO LAST YEAR.
AS RECORDS DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. BUT WE ARE CERTAINLY
AWARE OF THE LEGISLATION THAT'S
PROCEEDING THIS YEAR. OR
FINANCIAL AID REFORM WE HAVE HAD
SOME DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
STUDENT AID COMMISSION REGARDING
THAT LEGISLATION- WE DON'T TIP
TYPICALLY TAKE A POSITION ON
LEGISLATIVE BILLS OR SPEAK TO A
PROPOSALS AND LEGISLATIVE POLICY
BILLS AND BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE
UNTIL WE'VE HAD. AN OPPORTUNITY
TO CONDUCT A FORMAL ANALYSIS OF
THE MEASURE. ABOUT SAID I
WOULDN'T KNOW THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS MADE
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS AND
INCREASE THE AND FINANCIAL AID
AND COLLEGE AFFORDABILITY MORE
BROADLY IN RECENT YEARS- IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME I WON'T LIST
ALL OF THEM BECAUSE THEY ARE.
PRETTY SUBSTANTIAL. ONE WAS JUST
HEARD IN THE SUBCOMMITTEE
EARLIER ON STUDENT HOUSING
STUDENT HOUSING GRANT PROGRAM.
AS WELL AS SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS IN COLLEGE SAVINGS
ACCOUNTS FOR LOW INCOME
STUDENTS- THE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA- AND ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENTS IN TERMS OF THEIR
OWN TECH FOR COFFEE GREEN.
REALLY TAKEN AN EMPHASIS AND
FOCUS ON EDUCING A LOT OF A
CORE COST DRIVERS THAT ARE
DRIVING COSTS. GETTING A KIND OF
A REAL ISSUE. IN ADDITION TO
SIGNIFICANT DIRECT FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE PROPOSALS THAT WERE
INCLUDED FOR INSTANCE IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT.
WHICH IS THIS EASY FOR THE
ENTITLEMENT EXPANSION AND THE
MCF. CLASS SCHOLARSHIP EXPANSION
AND REVISION THAT THE ONLY OTHER
STUFF. TOO AS WELL. THANK YOU
AND I'M ME JUST RISK BY- THE
LARGEST. STATING OBVIOUS OF
LEGISLATIVE DEAD TO DIFFERENT
THE BUDGET DEADLINE AND WE
PROBLEM HOPE. TO BE ABLE TO. A
TO DEAL WITH THE STUDENT AID
ISSUES IN THE CONTEXT OF THE
BUDGET SO EVEN IF- THERE IS AN
ANALYSIS YET. WHAT ABOUT THE
BUDGET YOU'RE READY TO DEAL WITH
THAT BECAUSE WE WANT TO DO
WHAT'S HERE IN THE BUDGET AND IT
PROVIDES SOME OF THE FUNDS THAT
MIGHT SUPPORT DIFFERENT THINGS
THAT EXIST. IN THAT BILL AND
ELSEWHERE AND SO. I WOULD JUST
NOT WANT TO TRIP OVER URSELVES
AND WAITING FOR A BILL WHEN WE
HAVE TO DO THE BUDGET BEFOREHAND
AND WE WANT TO MAKE A COMMITMENT
TO. TO ADDITIONAL STUDENT NADER
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT. ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES ON THIS. NOW FOR
SENATE GOVERNMENT CENTER GROW
JOB I JUST WANT TO- JUST. PUT IT
ON RECORD HERE AT THAT I'M-
ACTUALLY PRETTY EXCITED AT THE
FACT THAT. ACCORDING TO THE
NOTES HERE 46% OF CALIFORNIA
GRADUATES HAD- ABOUT THAT PART-BUT THAT THE AVERAGE DEBT FOR
CALIFORNIANS. FOR TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN AND TWENTY WAS
210-001-0020 FIVE PLACE IN THE
STATE THIRD LOWEST IN THE NATION
ON THIS MEASURE. AS FAR AS
AFFORDABILITY AND- NOTING HERE
THAT IS THAT A TEN CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES
HAVE SOME OF THE LOWEST IN THE
NATION UPON GRADUATION SO I JUST
THOUGHT I WOULD POINT OUT THAT.
THAT'S A GOOD AND THAT'S GOOD
NEWS THAT'S SOMETHING TO
CELEBRATE- ACROSS THE NATION I
THINK- YOU KNOW WE TALK ABOUT.
THE NEED FOR MORE AFFORDABLE
DEBT FREE COLLEGE I THINK WE'RE
DOING REALLY REALLY GREAT A
LITTLE THAT IS NOT THAT BAD I
THINK IT IT PUTS YOU IN THIS
ISSUE IN THE EDUCATION THAT
YOU'RE HAVING AND IT GIVES YOU A
LITTLE BIT OF. INTEREST IN THERE
SO- I'M JUST REALLY EXCITED TO
READ THAT AND I JUST WANNA SAY
KUDOS TO THE TICKET THERE
LEGISLATURE AND THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOLS FOR WORKING ON THAT.
ENDEAVOR THANK YOU APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS ANYTHING ELSE ON
THE SUN. THING NOTHING LET ME
THANK- UP- LEGISLATIVE ANALYSTS
REPRESENTATIVE IN THE OTHER
STATES. THAT WERE PREPARED TO
RESPOND WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY FIVE WHICH
IS ADDITIONAL PROPOSALS
REGARDING THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA AND WE HAVE THREE.
ARE PEOPLE PREPARED TO SPEAK UP-
JASON CONSTANT TOURISTS FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE AGE
OF BURTON AND FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AND
DAVID SEWARD FROM HASTINGS
COLLEGE OF THE LAW WILL GO IN
THAT ORDER WILL BEGIN WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
REDUCING CONCENTRATORS
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE A
STEADFAST OUR OFFICE TO
INTRODUCE ISSUE TWENTY FIVE
WHICH CONTAINS A SERIES OF UC IN
HASTINGS RELATED PROPOSALS. I
DESCRIBED IN THE SENATE DEMOCRAT
BUDGET PLAN- THE PLAN PROVIDES
YOU SEE AROUND TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTY MILLION DOLLARS
ADDITIONAL ONGOING GENERAL FUND
AS WELL AS NINE HUNDRED EIGHT
MILLION ADDITIONAL ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND. ABOVE THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. IT ALSO
PROVIDES HASTINGS ANADDITIONAL
THREE MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND ABOUT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. YOU CAN SEE
ALL THE PROPOSALS ON STARTING ON
PAGE THIRTY ONE OF YOUR AGENDA
YOU CAN SEE THERE ARE QUITE A
NUMBER OF PROPOSALS SO I WON'T
GO THROUGH EACH ITEM FOR THE
SAKE OF TIME. JUST NOTE- SOME OF
THE MORE. SOME OF THE LARGER
ITEMS HERE. I GENERALLY LARGEST
ITEMS IN THIS PACKAGE EXPAND
UPON PROPOSALS THAT WERE IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. THE LARGEST
ONGOING PROPOSAL. WOULD PROVIDE
AN ADDITIONAL TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS TO YOU SEE FOR.
FOR ITSELF FOR A FREEZING
CREASE. THAT ACTIVELY DOUBLES
THE BASIN PRIEST THAT WAS
PROPOSED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. AND PROVIDE YOU SEE
AROUND. A TEN PERCENT. INCREASE
ON THE GENERAL FUND BASE.
LIKEWISE THE LARGEST ONE TIME
PROPOSAL ALSO EXPANDS SO THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. ON THAT
PROPOSAL WOULD INCREASE THE
AMOUNT FOR DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
AND ENERGY EFFICIENCY PROJECTS
FROM A HUNDRED MILLION UNDER THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET TWO ONE
BILLION UNDER THE SENATE
DEMOCRATS PLANTS THAT'S A NINE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR INCREASE
. AND THEN OUR UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT- THAT NINE HUNDRED BILLION
DOLLARS WOULD HAVE A- WE'LL HAVE
A BROADER SCOPE THAT ALSO
INCLUDES CAPITAL OUTLAY IN
ADDITION TO DIFFERENT
MAINTENANCE AND ENERGY
EFFICIENCY- THE PLAN ALSO
PROVIDES ON GOING GENERAL FUND
FOR ONE PERCENTERS RESIDENT
UNDERGRADUATE MOMENT GROWTH THAT
YOU SEE. THIS GROWTH WOULD BE ON
TOP OF THE 1% PROPOSED UNDER THE
GOVERNOR'S CONTACTS THAT WOULD
BE IN TOTAL AT 2% GROWTH IN
TWENTY TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR.
AND THEN FUNDS FOR THAT GROWTH.
I DID NEXT YEAR'S BUDGET. ONLY
THE PLAN- HAS MANY OTHER- NEW
ITEMS THAT WERE NOT IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET- THEY RANGE
FROM STUDENT OUTREACH TO CERTAIN
STUDENT SERVICES TO THE C.
WORKER RIGHTS YOU SEE IN OUR
OPERATIONS AMONG MANY OTHER
AREAS. AND THEN FINALLY I JUST
WANTED TO NOTE THAT THERE IS ONE
A LANGUAGE ONLY ITEM IN THE
SENATE DEMOCRAT BUDGET PLAN. OF
THAT WOULD EXTEND THE- SUNSET
DATE FOR THE UC UMBILICAL CORD
BLOOD COLLECTION PROGRAM UNTIL
JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WILL MOVE TO THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU SAVOR
TALENT FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA I WANT TO THANK THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AND THE
ENTIRE SENATE FOR THE GENEROUS
FUNDING PROPOSALS FOR THE
UNIVERSITY IN THE INTEREST OF
TIME I'M AVAILABLE TO COMMENT ON
ANY ISSUE YOUR QUESTION ANSWER
QUESTIONS THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
WILL MOVE TO THE REPRESENTATIVE
OF THE HASTINGS COLLEGE OF THE
LAW. A GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE MY NAME IS DAVID SEWARD
I AM TO SEE A FULL HASTINGS
COLLEGE OF LAW- WE ARE
APPRECIATIVE OF THE SENATE FOR
INCLUDING IN THE BUDGET PLAN
THREE MILLION DOLLARS- WE'RE- V.
EIGHT R. COVER COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH THE RENAMING OF THE SCHOOL
AS- YOU MAY RECALL THE- ORDER
DIRECTORS. IN DECEMBER APPROVED-
A PROCESS A DIALOGUE WITH THE
LEGISLATURE TO RENAME THE
SCHOOL. IN LIGHT OF THE- LEGACY
OF THE SCHOOL'S FOUNDER STRESS
TAKES THINGS. WITH THREE MILLION
DOLLARS IS PRIMARILY NEEDED FOR
THINGS SUCH AS BUILDING SIGNAGE
IT COST. OF LIVING SPACE IS A
SOCIALLY WITH CHANGING TITLE AS
WELL AS A MARKETING AND BRANDING
NOW THE- FUNDING THAT IS
INCLUDED IN THIS PROPOSAL. IS
FIGURES TO THE POINT OF. BEING
ABLE TO GO FORTH WITH A NEW
IDENTITY FOR THE SCHOOL WHICH
HAS BEEN IN EXISTENCE FOR A
HUNDRED AND. FORTY FOUR YEARS
WAS GOING TO BE QUITE A PROCESS-
AND- THEY WILL PLAY BE. CUSTOMS
THAT STILL HAVE YET TO IDENTIFY
A WE ARE WORKING CLOSELY WITH
THE SPONSORS OF AB NINETEEN
THIRTY SIX SB TWELVE EIGHTY
EIGHT. THAT WOULD PROVIDE THE
STATUTORY OF BASES TO EFFECTUATE
THE NAME CHANGE AS IT DOES
REQUIRE CHANGES TO THE EDUCATION
CODE AFTER TAKING A QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I'M JUST
GOING TO MAKE AN OVERALL
COMMENT- HE BASICALLY WHEN WE
HAD OUR HEARINGS EARLIER IN THE
YEAR WE OUTLINED. WHAT WE
THOUGHT WERE THE UNRESOLVED
ISSUES ARE THE ISSUES THAT
NEEDED TO BE ADDRESSED IN THESE
PROPOSALS ADDRESS MOST OF FROM
FROM THE- THE MAJOR PROPOSAL OF
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE AND
BUILDING AND THE MAJOR PROPOSAL
OF- ON GOING BASED SUPPORT. TO
THINGS LIKE MAKING SURE THAT
ONCE WE ADDED BACK TO RESTORE-
UC COOPERATIVE EXTENSION UNDER
WE DON'T STOP BY NOT HAVING-
COLON THE VERY FIRST YEAR AND
START TO GO BACK TO RIGHT WHERE
WE WERE OR- HAVE THE- A UCLA
ANDERSON FORECAST INCLUDE
CLIMATE AND THEIR NUMBER OF
ISSUES HERE AND SO I'M JUST
PLEASE THEIR HERE. THEY ADDRESS
THE POINTS THAT WE RAISED IN
THOSE HEARINGS AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO ADVOCATING FOR THEM
AND- IN THE FINAL BUDGET PROCESS
LET ME ASK THEIR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM MY COLLEAGUES THE
CENTER OF TROUBLE NO CENTERMAN.
I AM A THE SENATE'S PROPOSALS
HERE IN PENN THEM I HAD ONE
QUESTION THIS MIGHT BE FOR
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA- GIVEN THE
HIGH. RATE OF INFLATION THIS
YEAR AND POTENTIALLY NEXT GOING
IN NEXT YEAR- IT ARE THAT IS THE
PROPOSED BUDGET IS SUFFICIENT TO
COVER UP. MADE TO KEEP PACE WITH
INFLATION. THANK YOU SIR THE
SENATE'S PROPOSAL WOULD ALLOW
THE UNIVERSITY TO KEEP UP WITH
INFLATION IT WOULD ALLOW US TO
COVER THE FULL REGION'S PROPOSED
BUDGET WITH SALARY INCREASES
THAT HAVE BEEN NEGOTIATED AND
OUR- LABOR CONTRACTS. AND IT
WOULD ALLOW US TO FIND THE OVER
TARGET STUDENTS THAT THE
UNIVERSITY ENROLLED IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE FOR WHICH WE
CURRENTLY HAVE NO FUNDING SO
WE'RE VERY THANKFUL THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU-
THAT COMPLETES OUR COMMENTS. ON
THIS I'M GLAD TO HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO WEAR THEM WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO
ISSUE TWENTY SIX WHICH IS VERY
SIMILAR CONCEPT. IT IS THE
SENATE PROPOSALS WITH REGARD TO
THE CSU SYSTEM AND WE HAVE A
PRESENTATION FROM LISA KING. OF
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
AND RUN STORM FROM THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM WILL GO IN THAT ORDER
WILL BEGIN WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. THANK YOU I
STOPPED ALSO PRESENT TO SEE IF
YOU PROPOSALS INCLUDING THE
SENATE DEMOCRATS BUDGET PLAN
NEED DURING YOUR TIME THE
BEGINNING ON PAGE THIRTY SIX. A
NUMBER OF ON GOING PROPOSALS THE
LARGEST OF WHICH IS FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION ONGOING ON TOP OF THE
AMOUNT INCLUDING THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET FOR THE FOUNDATION. THIS
WOULD INCREASE THE PROPOSED
BASED APPLICATION PROCESS HERE
FROM 5% IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. 16% UNDER THE SENATE
PLAN. THERE'S ALSO ONGOING
FUNDING PROPOSED BEGINNING IN
TWENTY TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR
FOR AN ADDITIONAL 1% INCREASE IN
RESIDENT UNDERGRADUATE
INVOLVEMENT ON TOP OF WHAT'S
REFLECTED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
MULTI YOUR CONTACT. AS WELL AS
ADDITIONAL ONGOING FUNDING FOR
VERY STUDENTS SUPPORT. INCLUDING
CHRIS YES HE'S GRADUATION
INITIATIVE AND STUDENT BASIC
NEEDS AFTER. TURN THE PAGE
YOU'LL SEE THAT THERE ARE ALSO A
NUMBER OF ONE TIME PROPOSALS.
TOTALING NINE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
FIVE MILLION FOR CSU IN TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE. THE LAST
MAJORITY OF THIS FUNDING WOULD
GO TOWARD ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE AND CAPITAL
OUTLAY. WHEN COMBINED WITH THE
NOT PROVIDING THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET BRING TOTAL FUNDING FOR
THIS PURPOSE TO ONE BILLION IN
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE.
THERE ARE ALSO A NUMBER OF ONE
TIME PROGRAMMATIC AUGMENTATIONS
WHICH ARE LISTED MORE THAN. IN
YOU I'D BE HAPPY TO CLASS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND NOW WILL MOVE
TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM. THANK YOU
AGAINST CENTER LAYERED. SENATORS
MY NAME IS RYAN STORE FROM THE
CSU. THE GOVERNOR SPENDING
PROPOSAL FOR TWENTY TO TWENTY
THREE IS MEANINGFUL AND
CONSEQUENTIAL. BUT THERE ARE
MORE THERE- BUT MORE FUNDING IS
BEING SOUGHT OUT FOR THIS ISSUES
TWENTY THREE CAMPUSES SO THAT WE
CAN PROVIDE VERY COMPETITIVE
SALARIES POSITION POINTS. IN
ORDER TO REDUCE HER EQUITY GAPS
IN TO MEET THE GROWING
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS OUR
CAMPUSES. NOW THE SENATE WELL TO
WORK A PLAN SUBSTANTIALLY HELPS
WITH MEETING THAT FISCAL NEED.
AND REMAINING FUNDING GAP I'D
LIKE TO TAKE TO TAKE THE SENATE
IN PARTICULAR BECAUSE THE
ELEMENTS OF THE SENATE BUDGET
PLAN ARE CONSISTENT WITH OUR
PRIORITIES. ARTICULATED BORDER
TRUSTEES REQUEST ANOTHER WORDS
WE SEE EYE TO EYE ON THE
IMPORTANCE OF EMPLOYEE
COMPENSATION GRADUATION ISSUE
INFRASTRUCTURE STUDENT BASIC
NEEDS ANIMAL MICRO. SOME HAVE
FOR THIS ISSUE I THINK THE
SENATE FOR INCLUDING AS MANY
NECESSARY INVESTMENTS IN THE
PLANT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
LET ME MAKE A COMMENT IT'S VERY
SIMILAR TO. THE ONE I JUST MADE
FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
WHICH IS AFTER HEARINGS IN
FEBRUARY WE REALLY A DEN A I'D-
ARE DIFFERENT THINGS THAT WE
THOUGHT. WE WERE NEEDS AND THIS
A PLAN ADDRESSES THEM WITH
REGARD TO ADDITIONAL OF BASS
AUGMENTATION WITH REGARD TO
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE WE ALREADY
TALKED ABOUT HOUSING. IN
INDIVIDUAL THINGS LIKE THE
REBUILD OF THE- THIS ONE PACIFIC
RANCH AFTER THE FIRE DESTROYED
IT. AND ALSO THE CSU GRADUATION
INITIATIVE AND I THINK. THAT
THIS IS VERY GOOD BECAUSE
THERE'S BEEN REAL PROGRESS MADE
IN GETTING TO FOUR YEAR
GRADUATION RATES AT CSU WHICH
WILL ADDRESS SOME OF THE
ENROLLMENT ISSUES IF PEOPLE
GRADUATED FOUR YEARS AND- IT
BOTH HELPS PEOPLE. WITH NEEDING
LESS FINANCIAL AID BUT IT ALSO
HELPS CREATE SPOTS FOR OTHERS IF
PEOPLE MOVE THROUGH IT FOR
YEARS. AND THERE MIGHT BE A
CONVERSATION TO BE HAD ABOUT
CERTAIN METRICS THAT UP. IS THAT
MEASURE THAT OR REALLY MAKE SURE
THAT THAT'S TARGETED TO THE
CAMPUSES WHERE THERE. THERE
HASN'T BEEN AS MUCH PROGRESS AS
OTHERS SO- JUST MAKE THAT NOTE
AND I WOULD ASK MY COLLEAGUES IF
THEY HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ON THE SIDE. SENATOR
MAN DOESN'T- APPARENTLY NEITHER
TO CENTER A JOB OF- SO I
APPRECIATE THAT AND WE'LL MOVE
ON TO ISSUE TWENTY SEVEN. WHICH
IS THE VARIOUS SENATE PROPOSALS
WITH REGARD TO THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM AND WE HAVE PAUL
STEEN HOUSE AND FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
AND ONCE AGAIN WAS THAT NEVER AT
FROM THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE WILL GO IN
THAT ORDER AND WILL BEGIN. WITH
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. THANK YOU WHERE'D-
HOUSING WITH THE LEGISLATURE
ANALYST'S. STAFF IS ASSISTING
REDUCE. ISSUE TWENTY SEVEN WHICH
CONTAINS SIXTEEN COMMUNITY
COLLEGE PROPOSALS IN THE SENATE
DEMOCRAT BUDGET PLAN. WHEN
COMBINED WITH THE PROPOSED
INCREASE FOR THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENT SUCCESS
COMPLETION GRANT. WHICH WAS
MENTIONED IN ISSUE TWENTY FOUR.
THE SENATE DEMOCRAT BUDGET PLAN
PROVIDES COMMUNITY COLLEGES
ABOUT ONE POINT THREE BILLION
DOLLARS IN ONGOING PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND. ABOVE
THE GOVERNOR'S JANUARY BUDGET.
AND THE PLAN ALSO PROVIDES ABOUT
ONE POINT THREE BILLION DOLLARS
MORE THAN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
IN ONE TIME FUNDS. THE LARGEST
ONGOING PROPOSAL PROVIDES SEVEN
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS MORE
THAN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IN
FUNDING FOR A PORTIONS WHICH ARE
ACTUALLY BECAUSE DISTRICTS
GENERAL PURPOSE MONIES. NO
LARGEST ONE TIME PROPOSAL IN THE
PLAN PROVIDES EIGHT HUNDRED
TWELVE MILLION DOLLARS. ON TOP
OF THE GOVERNOR'S JANUARY
PROPOSAL FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE. AT THE SENATE
DEMOCRAT BUDGET PLAN MAINLY
INCREASES FUNDING FOR EXISTING
COMMUNITY COLLEGE PROGRAMS SUCH
AS A STUDENT EQUITY AND
ACHIEVEMENT PROGRAM AND A
PROGRAM. DESIGNED TO SUPPORT
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES THE
PLAN DOES INCLUDE SOME NEW
INITIATIVES INCLUDING FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE TIME
FUNDS TO START. A NATIVE
AMERICAN STUDENT SUPPORT PROGRAM
AT TWENTY COLLEGES AND A FULL
SET OF PROPOSALS ARE LISTED ON
THE AGENDA BEGINNING ON PAGE
THIRTY NINE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND NOW MOVES TO THE
CHURCH COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. YOU SENATOR
LAYERED IN MEMBERS OF THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE LISTEN NEVER AT WITH
THE COMPANY NICHOLAS
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. I WANT TO
THANK THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
SENATE IN PARTICULAR WERE AT
THEIR ALIGNMENT AND SYNERGY SOME
OF THE KEY. THE PRIORITIES OF
CALIFORNIA'S COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AND DISTRICTS I WANT TO CALL
PARTICULAR ATTENTION AND
GRATITUDE TO THE COMMITMENT FOR
ON GOING TO RESOURCES THAT
INCREASE PER STUDENT FUNDING FOR
CALIFORNIA'S COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
ARE WE SUPPORT THESE EFFORTS. AS
THEY CAN ENSURE THAT WE PROVIDE
QUALITY INEQUITY IN OUR
EDUCATION AND ULTIMATELY
SUPPORTS USE JOURNEY TO SUCCESS.
I ALSO WANTED TO. CALL ATTENTION
TO PROPOSED INCREASES TO
EXISTING PROGRAMS ON GROUP
REALLY ARE AT A TIME WHEN WE
WANT TO FOCUS ON CORE
IMPLEMENTATION OF PROGRAMS THAT
ARE IN PLACE. AND ENSURE THAT
THEY ARE SUCCESSFUL SO THE
COMMITMENT TO EXISTING- MOSTLY
EXISTING RATHER THAN YOU- IS
APPRECIATED BY DISTRICTS. AND
LASTLY WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
WITH ONE TIME FUNDS TO REDUCE
OUR BACKLOG IN DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE- AND A PROPOSED
INVESTMENTS IN THIS AREA WOULD
SUPPORT DISTRICTS IN DOING NOT
IN THE SYSTEM OFFICE IN
RESTRAINT OF BACKING HAPPEN. DID
YOU HAVE ANY ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND LET ME MAKE THE COMMENT I
MADE ON THE PREVIOUS TWO
BRANCHES ONCE AGAIN. WHICH WOULD
IN OUR HEARINGS WE ERRED OUT
WHAT WE THOUGHT THERE WERE GREAT
NEEDS IN THE ADDRESS DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE ON GOING FUNDING-
THINGS LIKE THE- OF THE POINTED
THE MESA PROGRAM TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY KEEP PACE THAT NEXT UP
PROGRAM TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE'S NO CAP ON THE COLLEGES
AND THERE'S ENOUGH MONEY. TO
MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE. AVAIL
THEMSELVES OF IT- AND- ALL THE
CALL AND I THINK THEY REALLY
REFER. OF THE SENATE PRIORITIES
A GOOD WAY OR WORLD THIS BE OUR
STANCE HEADED INTO THE FINAL OF
BUDGET ON THIS ITEM ARE THERE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
MY COLLEAGUES KNOW FROM CENTER
NO FROM EITHER SENATOR SO. I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND LOOK
FORWARD TO. WORKING HARD TOWARD
WHAT'S IN THIS. ISSUE TWENTY
SEVEN AS WE MOVE FORWARD IN THE
BUDGET WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO ISSUE
TWENTY EIGHT WHICH IS CYBER
SECURITY AT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM WENT DOWN OUR-
DAN HANNAH WERE FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE POSTING
HOUSING FOR THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. ANALYSTS AT
AVERETTE AGAIN FROM THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE WE HAVE MICHELLE MILLION
OF FROM DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ON
STAND BY FOR QUESTIONS SO-
WHAT'S MOVING THAT ORDER ON
ISSUE TWENTY EIGHT CYBERSECURITY
BILL STARK WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. MORNING THAT. DAN
AND OUR DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE-
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES
ONE HUNDRED MILLION ON-
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND OF WHICH TWENTY FIVE
MILLION IS ON GOING. TO ADDRESS
THE MODERNIZATION OF CCC OUR
COMMUNITY CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES TECHNOLOGY
INFRASTRUCTURE INCLUDING
SENSITIVE DATA PROTECTION
EFFORTS AT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. THIS PROPOSAL MIRRORS
REQUEST INCLUDED IN THE LIST-
THE CHANCE OFFICES TO REQUEST TO
BETTER EQUIP COLLEGES TO PROTECT
THEIR DATA AGAINST ATTACKS.
SIMILAR TO THOSE ATTEMPTED OVER
THE PAST ACADEMIC YEAR. I'M
GOING FUNDING WOULD BE PRIMARILY
UTILIZE FOR DISTRICTS TO HIRE ON
CYBER SECURITY STAFF AS WELL AS
THE OTHER SYSTEM WIDE OVERSIGHT.
ONE TIME FUNDS WILL BE USED TO
PROVIDE SECURITY UPGRADES FOR
FOX NETWORKS AND CGC OF LIFE. I
WOULD NOT HAVE ANY ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE ABOUT
THIS INVESTMENT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I WILL MOVE ON TO- TO THE
LEGISLATIVE COUNCIL. MOSTLY
HOUSING WITH THE ANALYST'S
OFFICE NEAR MAINTAINING
INFORMATION SECURITY PREVENTING
FRAUD ARE CRITICAL TO COMMUNITY
COLLEGE OPERATIONS AND STUDENT
PRIVACY IS LAUDABLE THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S ADDRESSING THESE
IMPORTANT ISSUES IN JANUARY
BUDGET WE FIND MERIT WITH
SEVERAL ASPECTS OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS THERE'S A
NUMBER OF- THERE ON PAGES FORTY
TWO AND FORTY THREE OF YOUR
AGENDA. OUR RECOMMENDATIONS
WHICH ARE ON PAGES FORTY FIVE TO
FORTY SEVEN OF THE AGENDA ARE
REALLY CENTERED AROUND THE
ALLOCATION METHOD FOR THE
PROPOSED FUNDS AND THE
LEGISLATURES NEED IN SOME CASES
FOR CLARIFICATION MORE
INFORMATION FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION AND CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE ON OF HIS FINEST VISITED
PROPOSAL THE FIRST WE RECOMMEND
THE LEGISLATURE APPROVED THE
TWENTY THREE MILLION DOLLARS ON
GOING TO PROPOSE TO COLLEGES.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET DOES NOT
PROPOSE AN ALLOCATION METHOD FOR
THE FUNDS SO WE RECOMMEND
LEGISLATURE DIRECTED CANCERS
OFFICE TO DEVELOP AN ALLOCATION
THAT THAT THE PROVIDES A MINIMUM
BASE. AMOUNT OF FUNDING PER
DISTRICT. THE GOVERNOR OF HAS A
PROPOSAL. AIMED AT CREATING
STRONGER STATE LEVEL SYSTEM WELL
LEVEL OVERSIGHT AND ASSISTANCE
MISTER HANOVER JUST MENTION THAT
WE FIND MERIT WITHOUT POLICY
GOAL WE DO KNOW THAT THERE IS AS
PROPOSED STATEWIDE CYBERSECURITY
TEAMS A SYSTEM LEVEL OVERSIGHT
BODY. AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE
POSITIONS PROPOSED IN THE
POSITIONS ARE ACTUALLY IN THE
NEXT ISSUE- IN THE AGENDA.
REALLY TELL US COMPLAINTS OF
CREATE SENATE ORG COMPLEX
ORGANIZATIONAL STRUCTURE WITH
OVERLAPPING RESPONSIBILITIES AND
POTENTIALS OF POTENTIAL FOR
CONFLICTS OF INTEREST SO WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
REQUEST THE ADMINISTRATION AND
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE.
CLARIFIED THE DIVISION OF LABOR
AND THE DELINEATION OF FUNCTIONS
AMONG THESE VARIOUS OF PROPOSED
A STATE LEVEL ENTITIES. IS ALSO
A ONE TIME FUNDS THAT WOULD GO
TO COLLEGES AND SIXTY NINE
MILLION DOLLARS IN ALL WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
APPROVES THE MONEY BUT DIRECT
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE TO
ACCOUNT FOR THE SIZE OF THE
COLLEGE AS WELL AS ITS LEVEL OF
PREPAREDNESS. WHEN ALLOCATED
FUNDS AND PRIOR TO ALLOCATING
USE ONE TIME FUNDS. WE THINK THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE SHOULD
DEVELOP AND PROVIDE TO THE
LEGISLATURE PROPOSED ALLOCATION
FORMULA. ALSO SPECIFY WHAT ARE
THE MINIMUM STANDARDS OF THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE WANTS
COLLEGES TO GET UP TO. WITH
REGARD TO CYBER SECURITY AND
ALSO FOR THE ADMINISTRATION
CHANCES OFFICE IDENTIFIED WITH
THE ON GOING COST LIKELY WILL BE
FOR COLLEGES TO MEANT MAINTAIN.
CYBERSECURITY PREPAREDNESS.
FINALLY WITH REGARD TO THE CCC
APPLY PROPOSAL THIS IS A
PROPOSAL TO UPGRADE THE COMMON
APPLICATION PORTAL WE THINK BE
OBJECTIVE HAS MERIT. WE DO NOTE
IN OUR ANALYSIS YOU MINISTRATION
ONLY PROVIDES COST JUSTIFICATION
FOR ABORTION OF THE PROPOSED
FUNDING. WE RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE DIRECTLY
MINISTRATION PROVIDE FULL.
JUSTIFICATION BY MAJOR REVISION
. THANK YOU USE THAT IN. TO MAKE
A FINAL DECISION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL MOVE TO
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. THANK YOU
CENTER LAYERED IN MEMBERS OF THE
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEEWITH THAT
WITH THE TEAMSTERS OFFICE- OUR
SYSTEM NEEDS A STRONG INVESTMENT
IN TECHNOLOGY RESOURCES
ESPECIALLY AS ASSEMBLY SECURITY.
I NEED SENATE TAX- AND
RANSOMWARE ATTACKS CONTINUE TO
GROW IN TWENTY TWENTY TWO ALONE
WE'VE HAD TO ADDITIONAL
DISTRICTS BASED CYBERSECURITY
ATTACKS FOR A TOTAL OF SIX OVER
THE LAST THREE YEARS. THE
MODERNIZING STATE AND DISTRICT
TO KNOWLEDGE INFRASTRUCTURE
INCLUDING- THE ONBOARDING
PLATFORM OF CCC APPLY ARE
CRITICAL TO ENSURING THAT
FACULTY AND STUDENTS SENSITIVE
DATA ARE PROTECTED FROM THESE
ATTACKS THIS IS ONE OF THE KEY
PROPOSALS AND PRIORITIES BY THE
BOARD OF GOVERNORS. AND OURS OUR
SYSTEM BUDGET REQUEST. LOS
SECURITY MODERN INVESTMENTS ARE
TWO FOLD APPROACH RELYING ON
STATE AND LOCAL ACTION GIVEN OUR
GREEK DECENTRALIZED FUNCTION AND
OUR ROLE IN SUPPORTING SEA LEVEL
MONITORING. THE SMALL PORTION
WOULD- GO TILL I'M GOING
SOFTWARE COSTS SUCH AS- TWO
FACTOR ATHENTICATION AND OTHER
KEY SECURITY MEASURES BUT THE
MAJORITY OF RESOURCES WITH
SUPPORT IMPLEMENTATION FOR
ACCOUNTABILITY MONITORING IN
TAILORING WORDS. ON FOR IT
DISTRICTS THAT MAY HAVE LESS
MATURE TECHNOLOGY
INFRASTRUCTURES GIVEN THEIR SIZE
AND POTENTIAL OF RURAL LOCATION.
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT THESE
ACTIONS AND UPGRADES NOT BE DONE
IN THE SILO WE WANT TO TACKLE
GROWING TECHNOLOGY SECURITY RISK
AND THIS IS AN ONGOING EFFORT
THAT ADVANCES AS BAD ACTORS
BECOME MORE SOPHISTICATED IN
THEIR ATTACKS. SECOND WE WANT TO
MODERNIZE AND IMPROVE THE
STUDENT USER EXPERIENCE AS WE
REDESIGN CCC APPLY WE DON'T WANT
TO MAKE IT MORE DIFFICULT FOR
STUDENTS TO APPLY WHILE THE
ENHANCED SECURITY SERVICES. A
PRECARIOUS ART AND SCIENCE TO
ADD SECURITY WHILE CREATING A
MORE SEAMLESS EXPERIENCE IT'S A
COMPLEX ENDEAVOR ENDING GROWING
COMPLEX- SOCIETY BUT WE THINK
THIS IS A WORTHY EFFORT. LASTLY
AS PART OF OUR- THE STRATEGY IF
YOU WANT TO COLLECT ADDITIONAL
DATA AND ENSURE THAT DISTRICTS
HAVE MINIMUM LEVEL SECURITY ONE
KEY ELEMENT IS ENSURING THAT
DISTRICTS COMPLETE AN ANNUAL
CYBER SECURITY SELF ASSESSMENT.
IN ALIGNMENT WITH THE NATIONAL
INSTITUTE OF STANDARDS AND
TECHNOLOGY COMPUTER SYSTEMS
LABORATORY THESE ARE SOME OF THE
CAL SECURE STATE STANDARDS- THAT
ARE- THAT- EMBRACED BY EXPERTS
IN THE FIELD AND WE THINK ARE
WORTHY FOR DISTRICTS AS WELL.
HAPPY ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT IT'S
VERY PROPOSAL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FROM. JUST YOU HAVE MAYBE
ONE QUICKQUESTION AND IT GOT
HANDLED A LITTLE BIT BUT- THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST HAD
RECOMMENDATIONS AND ANALYSIS AND
I WAS GONNA ASK FINANCE AND-
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CHANCELLOR IF
YOU JUST COMMENT ON AND LET'S
START WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. AND DINNER HAVING TO
FINANCE AGAIN- I DON'T THINK WE
HAVE A FORMAL POSITION ON THE
ELYAS RECOMMENDATIONS AT THIS
TIME- AGAIN I DOUBT THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S POSITION WAS
DEVELOPED IN CONSULTATION. OR
UPON REVIEW OF THE REQUEST MADE
BY THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE THE
OVERALL GOAL OF THIS PROPOSAL.
IS REALLY TO ENSURE THAT- THE
NEEDS OF THE DISTRICT'S- AND
SYSTEM WIDE. ROLLING TO THEIR
CYBER SECURITY NEEDS ARE MET.
AND SO TO THE EXTENT THAT YOU
KNOW WERE ABLE TO BEST DO THAT
THROUGH A DIFFERENT PROCESS
THAT'S CERTAINLY SOMETHING
NUMBER. I WOULD ENGAGE IN
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE WITH THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE AND THE
LEGISLATURE. ON MOVING FORWARD
AS WE MOVE TOWARDS MARRIAGE AND
ABORTION. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
DOES THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE HAVE ANY
COMMENT ON THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST YOU SENATOR LATER JUST A
COUPLE OF COMMENTS I THINK THE
L. A. O. HIGHLIGHTS OVRALL
THEME OF WANTING ACCOUNTABILITY
ON THESE BONDS AND SHOWING THAT
DISTRICTS ARE MAKING PROGRESS SO
ON THAT IS AN AREA THAT IS OF
INTEREST TO US- AND SO ON AS
THEY SHARED IN MANY
CONVERSATIONS WITH YOU- WANT
OTHER IN INTEGRATION OF DATA
REPORTING WE ALSO WANT TO ENSURE
THAT WE'RE SUPPORTING DISTRICTS
THAT NEED THE GREATEST- PROGRESS
IN THEIR- TECHNOLOGY SECURITY
AND WE RECOGNIZE THAT THAT MAY
BE. SMALLER MORE RURAL DISTRICTS
SO WE DO HAVE A LINE IN SOME OF
THOSE AREAS AND DATA COLLECTION
IS A PRIORITY OUR BOARD OF
GOVERNORS IS CONSIDERING A
REGULATION CHANGES THAT WILL GET
COULD COMPLEMENT THESE AND
ENSURE THE DISTRICTS ARE
REPORTING WHEN THERE ARE
INCIDENTS OF SUSPECTED FRAUD THE
NEEDS FURTHER ANALYSIS THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I JUST MAKE
ONE COMMENT WHICH IS I
APPRECIATE EVERYBODY'S
PRESENTATION. IN THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE SAID IT WAS
INTERESTED IN CONVERSATIONS AND
I THINK WE'RE INTERESTED IN JUST
SEEING IF THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S ANALYSIS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS HAVE MERIT SO WE
WANT TO BE HAVING THOSE
CONVERSATIONS AS WE MOVE INTO
FINALIZING THE BUDGET DO YOU
HAVE ANY COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE. MEMBERS OR QUESTIONS NO FROM
THERE SO YOU VERY MUCH. ARE WE
APPRECIATE THAT WILL MOVE TO
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY NINE WHICH IS
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE STAND OF
STAFFING. WE'RE GONNA HAVE-
JENNIFER ACAC- FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE POSTING
HOUSE AND FROM THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE ANALYSTS AT
NAVARRO FROM THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE AND
WE'LL GO IN THAT ORDER DEPEND.
OF BEGIN WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. HI JENNIFER TALK TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES AN
INCREASE OF ONE POINT FOUR
MILLION ONGOING GENERAL FUND TO
SUPPORT NINE NEW POSITIONS. AT
THE CCC CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE IN
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE AND IN
ADDITIONAL ONE POINT FOUR
MILLION ONGOING GENERAL FUND TO
SUPPORT TEN ADDITIONAL NEW
POSITIONS IN TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR. THESE NEW RESOURCES WILL
AID THE CCC CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
AND SUPPORTING CURRICULUM
RELATED REFORMS TECHNOLOGY
MODERNIZATION EFFORTS AND
INCREASED IT OPERATIONS CAPACITY
FOR DATA ANALYSIS RESEARCH LEGAL
AFFAIRS DISTRICTS FISCAL HEALTH
MONITORING AND GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS. HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THIRTY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WILL NOW MOVE FORWARD WITH
PAUL SEEN HOUSING FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST OFFICE.
THANK YOU POLICY KNOWS WITH THE
ANALYST'S OFFICE OVER THE PAST
SEVERAL YEARS THE STATE HAS
GIVEN THE COMMITTEE BECAUSE
CHANCES OFFICE MORE MORE
RESPONSIBILITIES AND PROGRAMS TO
ADMINISTER. WE UNDERSTAND
ADDITIONAL POSITIONS MAY BE
WARRANTED TO CARRY OUT THIS
ADDITIONAL WORKLOAD. THE
GOVERNOR'S ACTUAL PROPOSALS- IT
OF A MIXED BAG JUSTIFICATION IN
SOME CASES FOR SOME POSITIONS
BUT NOT SUFFICIENTLY JUSTIFIED
IN OTHER CASES OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE SUMMARIZED
ON PAGES FIFTY TWO AND FIFTY
THREE OF THE AGENDA. SO FIRST WE
RECOMMEND APPROVAL OF TWO
SPECIALIST POSITIONS TO
IMPLEMENT TRANSFER REFORM
LEGISLATION THAT WAS SIGNED BY
THE GOVERNOR LAST FALL BUT WE
RECOMMEND MAKING THE POSITIONS
LIMITED TERM RATHER THAN
PERMANENT. AND HAVING THEM
SUNSET AT THE END OF THE- TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE
FISCAL YEAR WHICH IS WHEN HIS
SIDE TRANSFERABLE MEDITATION
COMMITTEE SUNSETS. SECOND WE
APPROVALS TO ADDITIONAL
SPECIALIST POSITIONS WILL BE
ASSIGNED TO BASIC NEEDS PROGRAMS
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES RISING
SCHOLARS NETWORK. BUT WE
RECOMMEND OF THE LEGISLATURE
BEGIN FUNDING FOR THOSE
POSITIONS IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE SO IN THE UPCOMING OF
BUDGET YEAR AND NOT WAIT T ADD
THESE POSITIONS IN TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR IS CURRENTLY
PROPOSED BY THE GOVERNOR. IN
THIS IS BECAUSE THESE PROGRAMS
ARE ARE STARTING UP RIGHT NOW TO
COLLEGES AND THEY COULD USE SOME
OVERSIGHT ASSISTANCE. THIRD WE
RECOMMEND REJECTING COUPLE
POSITIONS THAT WOULD BE ASSIGNED
TO ETHNIC STUDIES CURRICULUM AND
COMPETENCY BASED EDUCATION
CURRICULUM AND THAT'S BECAUSE
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE REPORTS
THAT THEY ALREADY HAVE TO
SPECIALIST POSITIONS WORKING IN
THOSE PROGRAMS. AS FOR THE OTHER
THIRTEEN PROPOSED POSITIONS THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE MAY NEED-
THESE POSITIONS BUT TO DATE- THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS PROVIDED
INSUFFICIENT DETAIL BACK UP TO
JUSTIFY THE POSITIONS. SO WE-
WITHHOLD RECOMMENDATION ON THOSE
POSITIONS I RECOMMEND. GIVING
THE ADMINISTRATION THE
OPPORTUNITY PROVIDE MORE DETAILS
AND MORE WORKLOAD JUSTIFICATION. AT THE MAY REVISION THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR STEEN
HAUSER I WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
LIST THE SET NOW BUT I THINK
FROM THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. GOOD
MORNING AND THE SENATOR CHILLIN
MEMBERS OF THE BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE AND CURRENTLY THEIR
CHANCES OFFICE DOES NOT HAVE THE
CAPACITY TO IMPLEMENT SOME OF
THE- MAJOR STATEWIDE PRIORITIES
OF THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION INCLUDING
RECENTLY AT NOT. ENACTED
PRIORITIES AND LAWS HE DAVID
CANCERS OFFICE ADMINISTERS OVER
A HUNDRED AND FIVE PROGRAMS
COMPARED TO THIRTY ONE JUST TEN
YEARS AGO WITH ONLY A HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY SEVEN STAFF. THE
CHANGES OFFICE VACANCY RATE FAR
BELOW I'M STATE AVERAGES IN THE
PROPOSED POSITIONS THAT WERE
SUBMITTED ON THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE AND BOARD OF GOVERNORS
ACTUALLY SUBMITTED THIRTY ONE
POSITION FOR REQUESTS. ON THIS
IS TO MEET I AND ADDRESS CORE
GAP AREAS INCLUDING POLICIES AND
INITIATIVES THAT- HIGH PROFILE
WORK IN COMPLEX WERE ACROSS A
HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN COLLEGES. IN
SOME OF OUR GREATEST. NEED TO-
AREAS THESE PROGRAMS INCLUDE
RISING SCHOLARS TRANSFER FORM
BACCALAUREATE DEGREE
IMPLEMENTATION COMMON COURSE
NUMBER IN FISCAL HELD. OPEN
EDUCATIONAL RESOURCES IN ZERO
TAX COST INCREASE STUDENT
RETENTION STRATEGIES HOW FRESH
FOOD SECURITY BASIC NEEDS
INITIATIVES MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS. DIGITAL
ACCESSIBILITY DIGITAL DIGITAL
COURSE CONTENT DEVELOPMENT
YOU'LL ENROLLMENT DATA SECURITY
I'LL BE TEACHING WHY SUPPORTS ON
TO NAME A FEW ABSENT RESOURCES
TO EXPAND. ON AND IMPLEMENT THIS
CRITICAL WORK INNOVATE AND-
ENSURE THAT IT IS WE ARE
COMPLIANT THE SYSTEM- THIS
LIMITS OUR ABILITY TO ACTUALLY
DELIVER ON THE HIGH EXPECTATIONS
THAT- SHOULD BE EXPECTED OF OUR
SYSTEM. THE LIMITED ABILITY TO
PROVIDE- THESE RESOURCES MEANS
THAT WE JUST PILE LAUNCH MORE
WORK. AND IT ALSO DELAYS- TIME.
TO REPORTS AND ANALYSIS THAT
MAYBE CRITICAL AND IN TO THE
GOVERNOR AND LET. INTENT AND
DELIVER. IN ADDITION BEES
POSITIONS ARE NECESSARY TO
PROVIDE HIGH QUALITY DATA
SYSTEMS AND COLLEGE LEVEL
DECISION MAKERS TO FOSTER
INTEGRITY INQUIRY TO SCALE
EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICES AND
DEVELOP AN UNDERSTANDING OF THE
SOLUTIONS AND CHALLENGES THAT
OUR COLLEGES ARE FACING. AS WE
WORK TOWARDS MORE EQUITABLE
STUDENT SUCCESS SO WE ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT IN- ORIGINAL
PROPOSAL OF THIRTY ONE POSITIONS
TO ENSURE THAT WE CAN ADEQUATELY
SERVE OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND- ONE COMMENT BEFORE WE GO
THERE. FOR THE PEOPLE IN THE
HEARING ROOM THE LIGHTS OR
STROBING APPARENTLY IT'S NOT A
SERIOUS ALARM SO JUST IN CASE
AND IF YOU WERE GETTING READY TO
EVACUATE THERE'S NO NEED TO. IF
THIS CONTINUES WE MIGHT ARE
THERE GOES OKAY I THOUGHT WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO DIVERT SOME MONEY
FROM THE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
BUDGET THAT WE WERE CONSIDERING.
IT SEEMS TO HAVE BEEN FIXED SO
LET ME MAKE A COMMENT ON THIS
ITEM WHICH IS THAT-THE POINTS
THAT WERE MADE IN THE
PRESENTATIONS WERE RIGHT. WE
HAVE ADDED ALL THESE DIFFERENT
RESPONSIBILITIES ON TO THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE AND WE SHOULD BUDGET
ACCORDINGLY. AND I'M SURE
THEY'LL BE A CHECK AS TO WHETHER
THIS IS THE ADEQUATE LEVEL WHEN
WE GO THROUGH IT BUT THE CONCEPT
IS RIGHTS SO. I'M GLAD THAT WE
HEARD ANY COMMENTS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES. SEEING NONE WE MOVED
TO THE LAST- ISSUE ITEM WE HAVE
ON THE AGENDA WHICH IS ISSUE
THIRTY. OF WHICH IS- THE STATE
LIBRARY AND- WE HAVE- JASON
CONSTANT TOURISTS FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE AND
GREG LUCAS THE CALIFORNIA STATE
LIBRARIAN WILL START WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE- I
WELCOME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
MR JASON CONCENTRA CELILO THIRTY
THIRTY- SUMMARIZES THE STATE
LIBRARY RELEVANT PROPOSALS IN
THE SENATE DEMOCRAT BUDGET PLAN
FOR. FASTEST INTRODUCED THOSE
ITEMS OVER TO THE QUICKLY. YOU
CAN FOLLOW ALONG ON THE LAST
PAGE OF YOUR AGENDA ON PAGE
FIFTY EIGHT SUMMARIZES THE TWO
PROPOSALS- SPECIFICALLY RELATED
TO THE STATE LIBRARY. ON THE
FIRST PROPOSAL OF THEIR WOULD
PROVIDE SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND. OVER THREE YEARS FOR LOCAL
LIBRARY INFRASTRUCTURE GRANTS
FOR CONTEXT OF THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO BUDGET PROVIDED
THREE HUNDRED FOUR HUNDRED AND
THIRTY NINE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THIS PURPOSE. SO IN COMBINATION
A TOTAL FUNDING FOR THE PROGRAM
WOULD BE CLOSE TO ONE POINT TWO
BILLION DOLLARS. OF THIS PROGRAM
WOULD HAVE A SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT
SCOPE FROM THE- PROGRAM THAT WAS
ADOPTED IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET
LAST YEAR'S BUDGET- REQUIRES THE
STATE LIBRARY TO PRIORITIZE
FUNDING FOR PROJECTS THAT ARE.
CRITICAL MAINTENANCE OUR LIFE
SAFETY PROJECTS. ACCORDING TO A
GENDER THIS PROPOSAL WOULD HAVE
A SOMEWHAT BROADER SCOPE.
FOCUSING ON CAPITAL OUTLAY
EXPANDED ACCESS TO LIBRARIES
ENERGY EFFICIENCY AND
SUSTAINABILITY AND COMMUNITY
RESILIENCY. THE SECOND PROPOSAL
LISTED ON ON ON YOUR AGENDA OF
PROVIDE WOULD PROVIDE THREE
MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND. TO HELP RENOVATE- THE
HOLOCAUST- CENTER LIBRARY AND
ARCHIVES BUILDING. THIS IS A
BUILDING THAT'S MANAGED BY
JEWISH FAMILY AND CHILDREN'S
SERVICES A PRIVATE NONPROFIT
AND- THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WILL MOVE TO THE STATE
LIBRARY AND WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE. OKAY THANK YOU
SENATOR GREG LUCAS FROM THE
STATE LIBRARY I CAN'T IMPROVE ON
JASON SUMMARY OR THE VERY
THOROUGH ANALYSIS IN YOUR AGENDA
. I APPRECIATE THAT AND- LET ME
JUST MAKE A COMMENT WHICH IS
THAT- E. AS I MOVED AROUND THE
STAGE. AFTER LAST YEAR'S BUDGET
I JUST GOT THANKED EVERYWHERE
FOR WHAT WE DID LAST YEAR ON
STATE LIBRARIES AND IT'S CLEAR
THAT WHAT WE DID LAST YEAR WAS
OVER SUBSCRIBED THERE WAS A REAL
NEED IT IS REALLY LOGICAL FOR
ONE TIME FUNDING AND THAT IS
WHAT'S HERE AND SO. I'M PLEASED
THAT IT'S HERE AND GLAD THAT THE
SENATE IS RECOMMENDING IT TO AND
- LOOK FORWARD TO TAKING IT TO
THE- OF BUDGET DISCUSSIONS LET
ME ASK IF THERE ARE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES. THERE THERE ARE NONE
. SO EASY- THE THAT COMPLETES
OUR CONSIDERATION OF THE ISSUES
BUT WE HAVE PUBLIC COMMENT AND
THEN WE'R GONNA GO TO VOTE ONLY
AND I THINK THAT WE HAVE MOVED
TO A PLACE NAY GENDA THAT FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT I'M GOING TO HAVE
TO JUST ASK FOR YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND WHAT YOUR
POSITION IS ON ONE OF THE
BUDGETS WHETHER YOU SUPPORT THE
ALLOCATION YOU DON'T SUPPORT YOU
WANT MORE BUT JUST VERY BRIEF
POSITION AND THEN WE WILL ALLOW
PEOPLE TO REVISE AND EXTEND
THEIR COMMENTS IN WRITING AND
SUBMIT THEM TO US. SO WE'RE
GONNA MOVE TO PUBLIC COMMENT AND
BEFORE. WE GO TO THE-
TELECONFERENCE CENTER THEIR
NUMBER OF PEOPLE HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM LET'S GO TO THE
COMMITTEE WROTE ANYBODY HAVE
PUBLIC COMMENT TO THE COMMITTEE
AND YOU CAN LINE UP- SOCIALLY
DISTANCED APPROPRIATELY AND- THE
SERGEANTS WILL TELL YOU HERE
AND- JUST GO FOR THE NAME
ORGANIZATION AND TO. YOUR
POSITION. WELCOME GOOD MORNING
CARE LAYERED SUBCOMMITTEE
MEMBERS AMBER MAY CEO OF THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL ON SCIENCE
AND TECHNOLOGY IN SUPPORT OF
ISSUE TWENTY SIX ONE TIME FUNDS
FOR THIS A CCSD SCIENCE FELLOWS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE IN WAITING
HERE TO THAT HAVE TO BE SO BRIEF
SO WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS WE HAVE A CAT
AND THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
THE PLAN TO PROJECT AND I JUST
WANNA THANK YOU FOR THE THREE
MILLION DOLLAR PROPOSED
ALLOCATION. TO THE PROGRAMMING
WHICH WILL GO TO HELP EXPAND
ACCESS TO STUDENTS AND PROMOTE
TRANSFORMATION THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH HI THERE GRAYSON
BRAUN FROM POINT A AYE THE
FORMER COMMUNICATIVE STUDENT A
FORMER- COMING COLLEGE FACULTY
AND HERE PART OF THE POINT THE
PROGRAM THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THE ADDITIONAL FUNDING IS GOING
TO GO TO STEM PROGRAMMING FOR
STUDENTS ACROSS THE SEVENTY FIVE
CAMPUSES THAT WE CURRENTLY HAVE
WE'RE ALSO PLEASED TO EXPAND OUR
CAPACITY TO ALL A HUNDRED
SIXTEEN TO BE A COLLEGE STUDENT
THAT'S A LITTLE MORE THAN A
BRIEF POSITION. THANK YOU VERY
THAT WE APPRECIATE YOUR LOW- IT
WAS A JUST A ONE. SOME
REPRESENTING THE UC- IRVINE
UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS PROGRAM.
AND I'M HERE TO ASK YOU TO
SUPPORT THE FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
IN ONGOING FUNDING- PLEASE HELP
US CLOSE THIS GAP IN SUPPORT
SERVICES FOR FORMERLY
INCARCERATED STUDENTS. USE
SUPPORTED CCC HAS USE WE SUPPORT
THE UC THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WELCOME HELLO MY NAME IS A
FINANCIAL NINE I'M THE INTERIM
DIRECTOR OF. SECONDARY DIRECTOR
FOR THE WHEN THE PROJECT. AND
FIRST OF ALL I WANT TO THANK YOU
ALL OF YOU. FOR MAKING WITHOUT
PRIORITY IN THE CALIFORNIA STATE
BUDGET- WITH- AND I'M HERE TO
SUPPORT THE AUGMENTATION THAT
WOULD ALLOW US TO DO A WARM HAND
OFF. TO THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
OUR SECONDARY STUDENTS THAT ARE
GOING INTO GOING TO COLLEGE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
YOU WAITING HERE. WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME'S KATHERINE HUTCHINSON I'M
PRESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY IN PLACE SHE AN
ADVOCACY ISSUE TEN ISLANDS AND
CAMERA AND I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR ITEM NUMBER TWENTY SIX ROCK
MANY THE BUDGET AND THAT IN THE
FOUR HUNDRED MILLION. TO SUPPORT
THE STAFF. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS TYLER
GONE BY I AN UNDERGROUND. AT UC
IRVINE AND I'M HERE TO ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT FOR ONGOING
ALLOCATION OF FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS TO THE PROGRAM TO HELP
STUDENTS LIKE ME SIX FEET IN THE
UNIVERSITY STUDY. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. HI MY NAME
IS OTHER DAYS ROBBIE I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF THE UC BERKELEY
UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS PROGRAM AND
I'M HERE TO ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
FOR ON GOING FOR MILLION DOLLAR
ALLOCATION AS WELL AS THE ONE
TIME ALLOCATION FOR UC IRVINE'S
LIFTED. GRAHAM THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. HI MY NAME IS DANIEL.
BURKE ENERGON SCHOLARS STUDENTS
I AM ALSO A POLICY FELLOW WITH
THE U. S. SITE WITHIN A FEW
HOURS INITIATIVE. AND TRANSFER
COORDINATOR AT BIRKENAU
SCHOLARS. AND I'M HERE FOR
SUPPORT OF THE FORMING DOLLAR
ONGOING FUNDING. FOR THE
ORGANIZATION THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. HELLO GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS FORTUNATE TO GARCIA. I
WORK AT FRESNO STATE AS A LEAD
GROUNDS WORKER BEEN THERE TEN
YEARS. FUNDING THE SELLERS
THIRTY WERE ADEQUATELY COMPARE
COMPENSATE THOUSANDS OF STAFF
ACROSS TWENTY FOUR CAMPUSES. AND
WILL FIX THE BROKEN SYSTEM THANK
YOU FOR SUPPORTING THE FUNDING
AND IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
SELLER'S STEADY. IN YOUR BUDGET
HOPE OUR HOPE IS THAT EVERYONE
CAN WORK TOGETHER TO SEE THE
SELLER STUDY. IS FULLY FUNDED IN
THE STATE BUDGET THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. HOPEFULLY YOU CAN
HEAR ME I WE CAN WE CAN. MY NAME
IS MAKING THE CLOUD AND I WORK
AT CAL STATE FULLERTON I'VE BEEN
AN EMPLOYEE OF THE C. ISSUE FOR
THIRTY FIVE YEARS. AND I WORK IN
THE SCHOOL OF NURSING HANDLING
THE BUDGET AND I'M HERE TO SAY
THANK YOU AND WE FULLY SUPPORT
THE AUGMENTATION TO SUPPORT
STAFF SALARIES THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMENT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE- HI GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS HECTOR MY CELL I WORK AT CAL
POLY POMONA- NINETEEN YEARS
THERE- INSTRUCTORS SUPPORT
TECHNICIAN WHAT THAT MEANS AYE
AYES AYE SET UP. FRESHMAN LABS.
FOR NEW STUDENTS. I JUST WANT TO
THANK THE SENATE BUDGET
COMMITTEE- FOR THE SALARY SURVEY
RECOMMENDATIONS APPROVAL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN VERSE CRISTINA TO CARL
HERE WITH MIKE DILLON WERE THE
LOBBYIST FOR THE CALIFORNIA
LIBRARY ASSOCIATION WE WOULD
LIKE TO JUST EXPRESS OUR STRONG
SUPPORT FOR THE SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
PUBLIC LIBRARY CONSTRUCTION WE
WOULD LIKE TO THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP THE
SENATE PRESIDENT PRO TEM AND
SENATOR SKINNER FOR TWO YEARS IN
A ROW OF THIS AMAZING
OPPORTUNITY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. GOOD MORNING SERRA
SCHRADER FROM THAT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
EMPLOYEES UNIT AMONG PLAY AT
TENNESSEE STATE UNIVERSITY. AND
I'M- WANTING TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORT FOR ITEM TWENTY SIX
TO FUND THE SALARY STUDY
RECOMMENDATIONS THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
JOSHUA HAGEN ON BEHALF OF THE
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY
SPEAKING ON ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
FOUR FIRST AND FOREMOST THANK
YOU FOR ALL OF YOUR WORK TO PAVE
A PATH TOWARDS DEBT FREE COLLEGE
IN CALIFORNIA. YOU'RE MAKING A
TREMENDOUS DIFFERENCE IN WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT YOU
PROVIDE THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN ONGOING
FUNDING FOR THE CAL GRANT EQUITY
FRAMEWORK THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. HI MY NAME IS ERIN
MCCALL AND I AM A FORMERLY
INCARCERATED STUDENT AT UC
BERKELEY- I'M A SENIOR MAJORING
IN LEGAL STUDIES AND- AT UC
BERKELEY YOU WEREN'T
INCARCERATED YES I AM. NO I WAS
NOT. HI I JUST THOUGHT I WOULD
CLARIFY THAT THEY THINK YEAH
DURING SO I APPRECIATE THAT. AND
YEAH AND I JUST I WANTED TO I AM
THE WELLNESS COORDINATOR WITH
UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS AND I AM A
TREASURE OF THE STERN ORG. AND I
WOULD REALLY IT WOULD REALLY
MEAN A LOT IF YOU WOULD. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WE APPRECIATE YOU
BEING HERE. HI MY NAME IS
MICHELLE MAXWELL AND WITH THE
BERKELEY UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS
WERE SERVICE IN INCARCERATED
SCHOLARS PROGRAM COORDINATOR. I
AM HERE TO ASK YOU TO SUPPORT
THE FOUR MILLION DOLLARS IN
ONGOING FUNDING SO CAN HELP
STUDENTS LIKE ME THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD MORNING TERM
MEMBERS JENNISON ALLEY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION JUST
WANTED TO EXPRESS OUR GRATITUDE-
FOR THE CSU. FACULTY STAFF
FUNDING AS WELL AS OUR SUPPORT
FOR STRONG SUPPORT. FOR THE
THIRTEEN MILLION DOLLAR
AUGMENTATION. FOR THE UC LABOR
CENTERS THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE. MORNING MY NAME IS
TERRY WILSON I WATER FRESNO
STATE AS AN ADMINISTRATIVE
ANALYST AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT FOR ISSUE TWENTY SIX.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. KIMBERLY
ROSENBERGER WITH US YEAH YOU I
JUST WANNA ECHO OF THE PRESHEAF
AND GRATITUDE FOR BOTH YOUR
STAFF IN THIS COMMITTEE IN YOUR
LEADERSHIP FOR PRIORITIZING
WORKFORCE AND ITEM TWENTY SIX IN
AUGMENTING THE ISSUES THE BILL
CFA AND SAYS YOU YOU RAISE WE
WOULD LIKE TO JUST REYES.
CONTINUED CONSIDERATION OF
EXPANDING THE SUMMER BRIDGE
PROGRAM THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
THAT HELPS PROVIDE AN IMPORTANT
SAFETY NET TO WORKERS THAT DON'T
HAVE ANY RESOURCES DURING THE
SUMMER MONTHS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD MORNING
STEPHANIE GOLDMAN I'M WE HAVE
THE FACULTY ASSOCIATION OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
YOU JUST WANT EXPRESS OUR
GRATITUDE. FOR THE A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE PREPARATION FUNDING
STUDENT SUPPORT SERVICES- AND WE
WOULD LIKE TO ALSO- EXPRESS
THEIR SUPPORT FOR ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY NINE. THANK YOU.
LAWMAKERS WHO RUN TO THE MOST OF
YOUR DATA AS TO SUPPORT THE
EXPANSION OF UC IRVINE'S LIFTED
PROGRAM. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME'S BASICALLY I'M WITH
ASIAN AMERICANS ADVANCING
JUSTICE CALIFORNIA I'M HERE TO
SUPPORT ISSUE TWENTY SIX
SPECIFICALLY THE CSU ARM. ASIAN
BILINGUAL TEACHER EDUCATION
PROGRAM WE BELIEVE THAT THIS
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS INVESTMENT
IT IS AN INVESTMENT TO ATTRACT
MORE CULTURALLY AND-
LINGUISTICALLY COMPETENT TEACHER
TO FUSION. ASIAN LANGUAGES I DO
IMMERSION CLASSROOMS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- THAT APPEARS TO
COMPLETE ANY COMMENTS WE HAVE.
THAT ARE IN THE ROOM AND SEWER
MODERATOR WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
THE PHONE LINE AND- AND TAKE ANY
PUBLIC COMMENTS AND LET ME JUST
REMIND EVERYONE WE'RE TRYING TO
DO THE SAME THING WE JUST DID
WHICH IS NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION ON THE ISSUE SO THAT WE
CAN HEAR AS MANY COMMENTS AS
POSSIBLE SO MODERATOR. WELCOME
TO THE COMMITTEE. THANK YOU
SHARE AND AS A REMINDER WE DO
CURRENTLY HAVE THIRTY SEVEN IN
Q. I WILL GO AHEAD AND RE
PROMPTED IF YOU WISH TO PLACE
YOURSELF INTO THE QUEUE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND MODERATOR OF SOMEHOW.
WHENEVER YOU HAVE THIRTY SEVEN
IT GENERALLY MEANS OR SEVENTY
FOUR PEOPLE THEY'RE WILLING TO
TALK AND WE WILL HAVE A LIMIT AT
SOME POINT AND WE STILL HAVE TO
DO THE VOTE ON LEASE WE'RE
TRYING TO BE DONE BY ELEVEN
THIRTY SO LET ME JUST SAY. TO
THE- OF PEOPLE THERE WILL
PROBABLY GO TOE. ELEVEN THIRTY
FIVE AND ACCOMMODATE ANYBODY
THAT CAN JUST SAY THEIR NAME AND
POSITION. OF BY ELEVEN THIRTY
FIVE AND ANY EXTRA SECOND YOU
TAKE AS A SECOND SOMEBODY ELSE
DOESN'T HAVE SO. MODERATE LET'S
GO TO THE PHONES AND LET'S DO
OUR BEST TO ACCOMMODATE AS MANY
PEOPLE AS WE CAN BY ELEVEN
THIRTY FIVE. CERTAINLY MISTER
CHAIR WILL START WITH LINE
NUMBER TWENTY THREE THAT'S TWO
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU SO MUCH WATER AIR CARE AND
MEMBERS. ARE WHICH TO GET HE I.
EDUCATOR AND CLASSIFIED
PROFESSIONAL WE WANT TO THANK
THE SENATE. FOR ITEM NUMBER ONE
. IT IS A SUPPORTER THIRTEEN
MILLION FOR THE UC LABOR CENTER
WE ADDITIONALLY URGED THE SENATE
TO INCLUDE TWO HUNDRED MILLION
FOR HEALTHCARE FOR PART TIME
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FACULTY AND
HOPE THE FINAL BUDGET FURTHER
INCLUDES- BRIDGE. PROGRAM FOUR
FIVE FIVE MINUTE COLLEGE STAFF
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER. NEXT
COLOURS LINE NUMBER FORTY SEVEN
AT FOUR SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
. YES HELLO MY NAME IS THE WAY
WALLACE- AND I FROM THIS YEAR
I'M FROM UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA
RIVERSIDE. HI I'M CALLING IN
SUPPORT FOR THIS THIRTY MILLION
AUGMENTATION FOR THE NEXT UP
PROGRAM AND TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE THEY- SPEAK FAST FUND
ALLOCATED PREPOSTEROUS EXCUSE
YOU SEE FOLKS WHO SURGERY. THE
PROGRAM OTHERS SPEAKERS
POPULATION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY. MUCH NEXT CALLER. NEXT
APPLY NUMBER FOR TWO THAT FOUR
TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SHARE ON
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY RIVERSIDE DRIVE RIGHT I'M
A FORMER PROSECUTOR AND I AM. OF
THE THIRTY AUGMENTATION FOR THE
NEXT PROGRAM AND TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE THAT GUARANTEES THAT
ALLOCATED OFF YOU THAT YET
EITHER NEED TO BE. ASSEMBLY TO
THE PROGRAMS THAT ARE SPECIFIC
TO THIS POPULATION WITHOUT THE
YARD ARTICLE IT'S PROGRAM I
WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
GRADUATE WHAT WHAT YOU CALM ALL
RIGHT DEFINITELY TO CLICK HERE
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. NEXT CALL
MY NUMBER SEVENTY THAT. WERE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO THANK
YOU IT IS OUT OF CALL YOU THE
NEW SERVICES. THEY THE SENATE
FOR INCLUDING- EXPRESS SUPPORT
FUNNY A DOCTOR YOU FOR OF THE-
URGES SENATE TO SUPPORT- TWENTY
THAT NINE DOLLARS ARE GOING FOR
SEE SAY APPROACH. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MUCH MINOR NEXT CALL.
A CALLER IS GOING SEVEN FIVE
SEVEN FIVE YOUR LINE IS. HI MY
NAME IS DRAW FROM OF THREE WE A
THIRTY MILLION ON. FOR THE NEXT
PROGRAM AND ADDITIONALLY
WRAPPING UP FUNDING FOR THE- NEW
SEASON THE COMPANY BY TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE THAT MAKES IT
CLEAR THAT OFF FUNDS MUST BE
USED FOR PROGRAMS THAT
SPECIFICALLY TARGET COSTING YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER. SIX
DOLLARS MY NUMBER SIX AT EIGHT
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS WITH MY AUNT AND I AM A
RENAISSANCE SCHOLARS ALUMNI
COMMUNITY BANKERS AND STRONGLY
SUPPORT. SIX MILLION DOLLARS IN
ONGOING FUNDS TO GO TOWARD OFFER
YOU THIRTY PROGRAMS IN FOUR
MILLION TO SUPPORT AN IMPACTED
STUDENTS. PARTICIPATING IN
UNDERGROUND VAULTS PROGRAMS AT
THE UC DAVIS CRITICAL THAT THE
COMEDIAN DOCTRINE WOULD LIKE
THEIR TV FRONT. DOOR ASSEMBLY TO
EXISTING PROGRAMS THANK YOU SO
MUCH HER GHOST LOGS THANK. YOU
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. NEXT LINE
EIGHTY. EIGHT EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING IS A LIST OF
THE- I AM A- AT UPON HUMBOLDT
AND I'M CALLING FOR. OF THIRTY
NO OBLIGATION FOR NEXT UP GRAHAM
THANK YOU THANK VERY MUCH
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. NEXT CALLER
IS LINE NUMBER FIFTEEN THAT'S
ONE FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
MY NAME IS PUTTING THEMSELVES IN
A NEW FORM OF MUSIC AND
GRADUATED FROM CONSUMERS FROM
THE COLLEGE AND THE CURRENT.
SACRAMENTO EIGHT I AM IN SUPPORT
OF THE THIRTY MILLION DOLLAR
ARGUMENTATION FOR THE NEXT
PROGRAM IN TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
THAT GUARANTEES THAT FUNDS
ALLOCATED FOR FOSTER YOUTH
SDSU'S INFUSED. THOUGH
EXCLUSIVELY TO PROGRAMS THAT ARE
SPECIFIC TO THIS POPULATION
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER. NEXT
CALLER LINE NUMBER FIVE THAT
EIGHT FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON KEREN MEMBERS MY
NAME IS MIKE. ON BEHALF OF UC
BERKELEY LAB NEXT RESEARCH
CENTER I'M CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT FOR THE THREE MILLION
BUT YEAH- PROCREATION I WANT TO
THANK THE CHAIR AND THE MEMBERS
AS WELL AS AN EXTRA TEN TOPICS
AND BETTER SKINNER. FOR THEIR
STRONG SUPPORT IN THE BUDGET
APPROPRIATION WHICH WILL ENSURE
THAT IN THE IN THE GRADUATE
STUDENTS GRADUATE STUDENTS ARE
SUPPORTED. THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU. VERY MUCH MODERATOR
NEXT CALLER. NEXT CALLER MY
NUMBER SEVENTY. THAT'S DOUBLES
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MEMBERS MY
NAME IS LAURA TORRES AND I'M
CALLING TO EXPRESS STRONG
SUPPORT FOR AN ITEM UNDER ISSUE
TWENTY SIX BUDGET ALLOCATION FOR
UC BERKELEY'S PRECARIOUSLY
UNDERFUNDED LOT NEXT RESEARCH
CENTER TO CONTINUE SUPPORTING
RELEVANT RESEARCH AND STUDENT
INTERNSHIPS FOCUS. ON
CALIFORNIA'S GROWING NOT NEXT
POPULATION THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND CONSIDERATION THANK YOU
VERY MUCH A MODERATOR NEXT
CALLER. NEXT COLOURS LINE NUMBER
SIXTY THREE THAT SIX THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MORNING TEN SENATE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS DANIEL MARKET
HAS I RECENTLY FINISHED MY
UNDERGRADUATE DEGREE ACT HOW IN
MAY OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND I
AM CALLING IN SUPPORT OF THE
THREE MILLION DOLLAR OPERATIONS
TO THE LATIN EXERCER CENTER.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER. NEXT
COLOURS LINE NUMBER SIXTY EIGHT
SIX EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS MY
NAME DATE. I'M A GRADUATE
STUDENT RESEARCH FELLOW THEY
CAN'T BE USED ARE YOU CALLING.
IN FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF THE
PREVIOUS OPERATION BUDGET
REQUEST I NEXT WEEK ENTER THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. NEXT
COLOURS LINE NUMBER TWENTY ONE
THAT'S TWO ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
. MY DOCTOR KNOCKED ANOTHER
EARLIER I'M GOING TO PUT UP THE
UC BERKELEY LAB NEXT RESEARCH
CENTER. ONE TIME FUNDING REPORT
I AM TWENTY SIX THE RESEARCH
CENTER UC BERKELEY WITH A
CRIMINAL MY DEVELOPMENT OF THE
SCHOLAR OF THE FIRST GENERATION
COLLEGE STUDENT. YOUR RIGOROUS
VETTING WRAPPED UP IN. TO
RESEARCH SOME OF THE BRIGHTEST
COLORS BASED. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR SUPPORT ON THAT SIDE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE.
YOUR COMMENTS MODERATOR NEXT
CALLER. NEXT CALL LINE NINE TWO
THE NINE TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING. OKAY I'M A FORMER
ATHLETE AND A GRADUATE. YEAH AND
I WON SUPPORT THE THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE NEXT PROGRAMS
THAT ALLOCATE. THE FOXY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR NEXT
CALLER. NEXT COLOURS. HELLO MY
NAME IS STEPHANIE FAN OF THE
TRANSFUSION PLENTY ACHE I
REPRESENT AUSTIN YOU THINK
WONDERFUL THREE FORTY BUT THIRTY
MILLION AUGMENTATION FOR THE
NEXT PROGRAM INTO A BUILDING
WHICH GUARANTEES THAT ANALOGY
FOR FOSTER YOUTH IN FOSTER
HOMES. I THOUGHT I THINK HE IS
ONE OF THE MORE FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH ARE ABLE TO GET FUNDING
FROM THE GARDEN OF FINANCIAL
STRESS AND FINISH SCHOOL THANK
YOU THANK YOU. VERY MUCH
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. NEXT LINE
NINETY SIX NINE SIX ONE OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS ROCKY DOG AND
MCCARTY IS AN EXCEPTION. CITY
COLLEGE I AM IN SUPPORT OF THE
THIRTY MILLION ON VACATION FOR
THE NEXT PROGRAM AND TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE THAT GUARANTEES
THE FUNDS ALLOCATED FOR COFFEE
HUGE AS HE IF YOU'VE BEEN USING
COAST POLITICALLY PROGRAMS THAT
ARE SPECIFIC TO THIS POPULATION
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. MODERATOR NEXT CALL.
NEXT CALLERS LINE NUMBER THIRTY
ONE THAT'S THREE ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
DANIELLE ONE DRILL WITH CHILDREN
NOW CALLING IN SUPPORT OF A FEW
ITEMS FIRST WE SUPPORT A THIRTY
MILLION DOLLAR AUGMENTATION THE
NEXT STEP PROGRAM. NEXT WE
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
TO PROVIDE SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE HIGHER
EDUCATION STUDENT HELPING GRANT
PROGRAM WHICH SUPPORTS THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO INCREASE
STUDENT FINANCIAL AID AND THE
SAYS SENATE. BETWEEN WEALTH THE
WORK PROPOSALS FOR FINANCIAL AID
REFORM AND FINALLY WE SUPPORT
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS TO
INCREASE THE FUNDING FOR THE UC
CSU AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. NEXT
COLOURS LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED
THREE THAT'S ONE ZERO THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THE MORNING CARE
AND MEMBERS ALEX CRAIG THE
ASSOCIATION OF INDEPENDENT HELP
MAKE COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES-
THAT IS WHAT THEY CALL EXPRESSED
SUPPORT IN ISSUE TWENTY FOUR FOR
THE TWENTY FIVE POINT NINE
MILLION PROPOSED BY THE ENATE.
TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE REMAINING
GAPS THE CAL GRANT PROGRAMS FOR
STUDENTS ATTENDING OUR
INSTITUTION THANK YOU ABOUT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR
NEXT CALLER. NEXT COLORS NINE
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND IX
THAT'S ONE ZERO SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN- IT'S BIGGER THAT THE ST
THE MODAL REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE FOR RETIRED
AMERICANS IN STRONG SUPPORT. IN
MILLION DOLLAR ONGOING- PROPOSAL
FOR YOU SEE WHAT THIS POLICY
RIGHT COLLABORATIVE WHICH IS
INSTRUMENTAL THEIR WORK THE
MIDDLE OF MY WORK MATHIS- THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR NEXT
CALLER. ONE IS OPEN. MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS CHARLES RIGHT ON
BEHALF OF THE CSU PALM DESERT WE
SUPPORT THE SEVENTY NINE MILLION
DOLLARS PROPOSAL TO FUND THE
FOUNDER CAMPUS STUDENT SUCCESS
CENTER THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR
NEXT CALL. NEXT CALLER MY NUMBER
SIXTY TWO THAT SIX TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS JOSHUA
POLICY HERE. I THANK YOU FOR
LEASE I'M A FORMER. FOR THE
THIRTY DOLLARS ARE. PROGRAM IN
THE COURT. IT'S LIKE YOU'RE
FUNDS. FOR THE THREE AT IN THE-
THANK YOU THANK YOU ARE VERY
MUCH MINOR NEXT CALL. SIX
DOLLARS NUMBER HUNDRED IN
SEVENTY THAT ONE ONE SAID YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
FORGET SAYING WITH NEXT THING
CALIFORNIA CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
THE CAL GRANT EQUITY FRAMEWORK
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT YOU
SUPPORT AND INVESTMENT OF THREE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION IN THE
STATE BUDGET IMPLEMENT- THE
FRAMEWORK WHICH WILL SUPPORT OUR
MOST NEEDY STUDENTS AND ACHIEVE.
THEIR COLLEGE BALL THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR COMMENT
MODERATOR LET ME KNOW WE HAVE
FIVE MINUTES LEFT SO WE'RE GONNA
TRY TO GET AS MANY PEOPLE IN
FIVE MINUTES AS WE CAN. NEXT
CALL. NEXT COLOURS LINE NUMBER
SIXTY ONE THAT SIX ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MY NAME IS JORDAN A
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH ALUMNI
CALIPHATE COLLECTING ARTICLES
PROGRAM CALLING WITH CALIFORNIA
YOUTH CONNECTION I'M CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF THE FAT BUT FIT OUT
EACH OF PERFORMANCE YOU SUPPORT
. IN HIGHER EDUCATION. I DON'T
BUT THE COMMITTEE PUT AFTER THE
BILL LANGUAGE THAT GUARANTEES
THE FINE COOK DIRECTLY TO
PROGRAMS TO PROVIDE DIRECT
SERVICES- AT PUBLIC POLICY AT
THE HIGHER EDUCATION THANK YOU
THANK YOU. VERY MUCH MODERATOR
NEXT CALLER. NEXT CALLER LINE
MEMBER THREE THAT'S IN THREE
YEAR LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS TO
NINE MERLIN I AM A FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH AND THEY GUARDIAN SCHOLAR
ALUMNI OF HEALTH STATE FULLER
TEN I AM CALLING IN SUPPORT OF A
THIRTY MILLION DOLLAR.
ARGUMENTATION FOR THE NEXT STEP
PROGRAM- CLOSEST TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE THAT GUARANTEES THE
FUNDS ALLOCATED FOR FOSTER YOUTH
THAT HE HAS TO USE AND USE
THESE. OTHER PEOPLE SIMPLY TO
PROGRAMS THAT ARE SPECIFIC TO
THIS POPULATION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MODERATOR NEXT CALL. NEXT
CALLER IS MY NUMBER FIFTY FOUR
THAT'S FIVE FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NINE FIFTY FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. FOR YES YOUR FIFTY FOUR
LET US HAVE IT AUTO ONE OF MY
VERY FAVORITE AT ALL CURRENT
BERKELEY I'M UNDER ROB FOWLER
HELPFUL I'M CALLING FROM
CORPORATE LOGO. ONLY THE THIRTY
DOLLAR I MEAN MILLION ARE
FORMING THE UNDERGROUND REALLY
INTO- ON THE TOP. OF YOUR THANK
YOU FOR MUCH MONTEREY NEXT CALL
. THE COLOURS LINE ONE HOW AND
EIGHTY THAT TO ONE EIGHT ZERO IS
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS MAY BE A
AN IMAGE AT UC BY AND I LIKE TO
THINK THAT IT BREAKS IN FUNDING
- PROVIDED A DOCTOR STUDENT
PROGRAM AND HERE TO ASK INCLUDE
OF TWENTY TWO POINT FIVE MILLION
. FUNDING FOR YOU HE A PATH
PROGRAM BECAUSE I THE DIGITAL
STUDENT MY COLLEGE THAT WOULD
NOT HAVE BEEN. WITHOUT A RECEIPT
WITH A THE CORPORATE ACCESS
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH MY
NEXT CALL. TECHNICOLOR'S ONE
NUMBER NINE ONE NINE ONE YOUR IS
OPEN- HI MY NAME IS AND MAY
AFFECT STUDENTS AT THE END OF
BARBARA I THINK THAT THANK THAT
BALLING FUNDING ARE. IN AND I
WOULD ALSO LIKE ASK IS N. HAVE
MONEY TO POINT FIVE DOLLARS IN
IT A FIVE EIGHT PROGRAM. HERE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MY NEXT. IS
CALLER IS GOING TO NINETY THAT
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY
AS WELL OCCASIONAL I'M NOT HI
EASY. YOU CAN FOR THEM DIRECTLY
TO THINK ABOUT IT THANK YOU JOHN
. BUT IT PROGRAM AND I LIKE
BEING PART THE IMAGE TO INCLUDE
TWO POINT MILLION FUND GO BEFORE
CAN EXPECT A PROGRAM WE LIKE THE
YOU. FIND IT HARD FOR THE.
WHAT THE SIXTIES ALL THE COURTS
AND I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF ATTY-
THE ONGOING TWENTY POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS BUDGET
ALLOCATION FOR SPEAK. AND I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO THANK YOU ALL
FOR YOUR ONTINUED SUPPORT FOR
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS AT TWENTY
TO PROGRAMS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. NEXT
COLOURS LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED
AND TWENTY TWO THAT'S ONE TWO
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS BETTY LAST
CLASS ON THE FORMER FOSTER YOUTH
AND MEMBER OF THE ORANGE CHAPTER
TWENTY YOU CONNECTION I'M
CALLING TO SUPPORT THE BUDGET
ALLOCATION FOR FUTURE SUPPORT
PROGRAM AND HIGHER EDUCATION IT
IS VITAL THAT THE COMMITTEE
ADOPTED THE LANGUAGE THANK EVERY
FEW THAT THE STATE FUNDS FOR
DIRECTLY TO THE PROGRAMS THAT
PROVIDE. DIRECT SERVICE TO
CURRENT AND FORMER BOSS USED AND
EDUCATION THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY. MUCH MODERATOR NEXT CALLER
. NEXT CALL LINE AND ONE AND
TWENTY NINE ONE TWO NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
EILEEN GOLAN FORMER YOUTH AND
PEER MENTOR AT CALCULATE VERY
SCHOLARS. I AM IN SUPPORT OF THE
THIRTY MILLION AUGMENTATION FOR
THE NEXT A PROGRAM REQUEST
CHERIE THEIR BILL LANGUAGE THAT
GUARANTEES. FUNDS ALLOCATED FOR
FOSTER YOUTH YES AND USE THESE
CARS TO IS SPEECH PROGRAMS ARE
SPECIFIC **** THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR ON. THIS
NEXT CALL WILL BE THE- CALL. SO
ARE NEXT CALL. FEDERAL KALRA
FROM LINE TWO FIVE SIX TWO FIVE
LINE IS A- THE MORNING CARE. ACT
IN REACH REP FOR CALIFORNIA
POLITICS CANCER OFTEN PROCESS OF
OUR VETERAN. AS SUPPORT CAL
COMMUNITY COLLEGE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING BUT AFTER SPUR THAT CAN
THAT MAKING ON GOAL. VETERANS
THREE FOR FROM TO MILLION TWENTY
FIVE BILLION THANK YOU THANK YOU
MUCH AND WHAT ME JUST. THAT THE
MODERATORS AT THE OUTSET THERE
WERE THIRTY PEOPLE ON THE LINE
AND WE WERE TO THIRTY SIX COMMON
SO I'M GRATEFUL AND FOR THOSE OF
YOU. THAT EITHER RAW TO EXTEND
YOUR COMMENTS OR DID GET IT- TO
PARTICIPATE ARM YOU CAN SUBMIT
YOUR COMMON OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE BUDGET IN FISCAL
REVIEW COMMITTEE OR YOU CAN
VISIT OUR WEBSITE OF THE
COMMENTS ARE VERY IMPORTANT TO
US. AND WE WOULD REALLY LIKE TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE CONSIDERED
THEM ARE WE HAVE ONE REMAINING
ITEM WHICH IS WE HAVE VOTE ONLY
ITEMS THE END OF WE'RE GOING TO
SPLIT THEM INTO TWO BLOCKS. OF
THERE'S ONE BALK THAT HAS
BECAUSE WE HAVE ITEMS ONE
THROUGH TWENTY ONE AND ONE BLOCK
IS ALL ITEMS ONE THROUGH TWENTY
ONE EXCEPT ONE TWELVE AND
FIFTEEN SO WOULD BE ALL THE
REMAINING ITEMS IS THERE A
MOTION ON THOSE SIDE ALL ITEMS
ONE TO TWENTY ONE EXCEPT. ONE
TWELVE AND FIFTY. MOTION BY A
CHAU BUG WITH CONSULTANT CALL
THE- CENTER LAYERED HI CENTER
LAYERED I SENATOR MEN. SENATOR
MEN I CENTER OCHO BOOK HI
SENATOR OTOBO HI THAT'S UP FIVE
THREE KNOWS ZERO THOSE ITEMS ARE
OUT AND THEN WE'RE GONNA HAVE A
MOTION FOR ITEM ONE TWELVE AND
FIFTY. SYNDROME HOW ABOUT A
MOTION FOR ONE TO OVER FIFTEEN
THEIR MOTION BY SENATOR MEANT A
WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE CENTER WHERE HI SENATOR
WHERRY HI SENATOR MEN. SENATOR
MAN HI SENATOR OTOBO. SO THAT'S
THAT HI ONE TWELVE AND FIFTY.
OKAY SO- STATE THAT'S A NOT
VOTING YET SELFIES TWO KNOWS
ZERO ABSTAINED ONE THEN- THOSE
ITEMS ARE OUT OF THAT COMPLETES
OUR BUSINESS AND I WANT TO THANK
EVERYBODY FOR BEARING WITH US
BECAUSE WE GOT A LOT DONE TODAY
WE HEARD A LOT OF OUR COMMENTS
ON THE INDIVIDUAL ITEMS AND A
LOT OF PUBLIC COMMENTS AND ONCE
AGAIN. IF YOU WANTED TO SUBMIT
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS YOU CAN DO
IT OR SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO
THE BUDGET IN FISCAL REVIEW
COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE
OF THOSE COMMENTS ARE VERY
IMPORTANT TO US- THANKS EVERYONE
FOR THEIR COOPERATION AND
PATIENCE THAT CONCLUDES TODAY'S
AGENDA THE SENATE BUDGET AND
FISCAL REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE ONE
ON EDUCATION STANDS. ADJOURNED.